joe biden
joe biden's america you know they said
that in uh
trump's america antifa was running
rampant and there was nothing we could
do to stop
it the media in trump's america was
defending antifa saying that they were
just
peaceful protesters that news you heard
about destruction and vandals and
right-wing conspiracy theories while
there are some violent people
the protests were overwhelmingly
peaceful and then something happened
joe biden became president inherited
this uh american problem
and i guess now antifa is wreaking havoc
in joe biden's america
one day not even one day is the
inauguration day
they went out and they smashed up the
democrat headquarters i think it was in
portland
among other protests burning american
flags trashing things in seattle
and the internet lit up ragging on joe
biden
and uh then something kind of hilarious
happened
twitter has banned several high profile
antifa related accounts
finally yeah after all of these years
the years spent of complaining about
left-wing extremists and terrorists
organizing on their platform and them
doing nothing
as soon as it's a problem for joe biden
gone
wonderful so we're gonna talk a bit
about this stuff we've got we've got
some other stories
in in in the same uh vein there's this
uh think tank
guy who tweeted a disparaging comment
about
mike pence well i should say disparaging
he tweeted that he should be
i don't know i won't even get into it
just he was bordering on threats of
violence
he lost his job now so uh it's funny how
we're making it this far
into the the uh double standard now
applying to the left
but it's all in the benefit of them so
we're gonna go through these stories
joining us today we've got
matt brainard matt do you want to
introduce yourself explain
who you are what you do sure um well i'm
probably best known as the former
director of data and strategy for
president trump's campaign
in 16. i lead look ahead america
51c3 dedicated to registering
educating and turning out to vote
disaffected patriotic americans as well
as
fighting for election reform and against
corporate censorship
and most recently i led the voter
integrity project which brought me here
last time so i'm very glad to be a a
return
guest right on right on bill grakowski
is here peddling t-shirts
howdy i am your uh friendly parking lot
dweller
and as you mentioned very humble t-shirt
defender
that sells all the shirts that he always
wears how pathetic am i we've got
great we have a bedroom here for luke he
doesn't want it
so when he's like i live in a parking
lot he's choosing to do that i'm a poor
man
[Laughter]
give me your monies go now on
thebestpoliticalshirts.com
or we are changing or forward slash
shirts whatever it is you know how it is
that that is a pretty good shirt you got
that
honestly we have the gorilla shirt it's
just not political at all and i don't
think our shirt's ever going to be
really political they might just be like
jokey
you know maybe cultural but it's pretty
good he doesn't have enough room for all
the uh
all the news bureaus there that could be
listed i know
it should be like a nascar suit to be
honest with you box is not on there
i don't i haven't checked it uh nope nut
box no
man is it washington washington post
we'll make we'll make them
we'll make another shirt don't worry
we'll make a full shirt no this isn't my
next shirt my next year it's going to be
a nascar
with all the corporate mainstream media
logos and it's going to say corporate
sellout right here i love it so
i'm going to write that down so i don't
forget it i get a cut of that right yes
yeah
five percent yes i am a gorilla
uh at least a descendant of one or we
have a similar ancestor i believe i am
the token liberal on the show
and i have smoked dmt i don't think
you're a liberal bro
no but i'm the token liberal on the show
but i'm not liberal yeah
undercover liberal that's right
undercover conservative you're
definitely not a liberal yeah like i s
like
liberals are in a weird sense i think
you got to be liberal and conservative
if you want to live a balanced life
just in the right time you know
sometimes you want to be concert
conservative sometimes you want to be
liberal about changing something
sometimes you want to make sure
something doesn't change like
conservation there's a nuance in all
things
there is no it's true that's true right
we also got sour patch lids pressing on
the buttons
over the corner i do press all the
buttons i'm wearing glasses tonight
here's tim there's so much news we also
have rachel maddow crying
because joe biden won and andrew
sullivan also crying
who are these people who started crying
when joe biden became president
they cried when trump became president
and they cried when trump left the
presidency
it's like they'll cry for anything man
you know what's funny i once read that
men
cry once a month and women cry six times
a month
but i gotta be honest i can't remember
the last time i cried i don't know maybe
i was just dead
cold-hearted cold-hearted uh dark
villain with no do you want to cry no i
got another cry over yeah i think six is
a little low too
it depends on the woman let's put it
that way well rachel maddow i think does
cry a lot and i mean that i'm not saying
that to be like haha she cries no she
really does she
when the mueller report you know came
out that trump wasn't
you know colluding with the russians he
was like fighting back tears and that
was really weird i've noticed
if i fast i'm more likely to cr like
more in touch with my emotions i can get
to crying quicker
more in touch though but i'm not in
control of i don't know
i'm like i couldn't make myself cry you
know it's like acting technique yeah
yeah yeah you know but or i could just
like not anyway
they cried so we've got a bunch of
stories to go through and this guy lost
his job and it's crazy and
you know auntie for getting bad before
we get started head over to timcast.com
my friends and become members to help
support the show we are trying to build
up a strong backbone a user base a
membership that will
protect us from censorship if we get
nuked across the board like many
channels have then we're gone but
if you go to timcast.com and you sign up
and we have a decent amount of
subscribers we can keep doing the show
forever and i guess you know there's
always a possibility they ban my website
outright but that seems
really really unlikely we got a we got a
post up the other night i don't know if
you saw
you know we were yelling about whether
or not trump is truly corrupt
and so we actually did another 20 or so
minutes just about 20 minutes
and it's a members only post and we're
all basically yelling at each other and
it's good fun
and that's at timcast.com a lot of
people have mentioned they're having
trouble with signing up
just email members at timcast.com and we
are getting it all fixed for everybody
the site is new and there is a i think
it's a third-party
problem so we have to like do some kind
of plug-in or integration
it's certain email addresses for
whatever reason but uh timcast.com
become a member and we just greatly
greatly appreciate it don't forget to
like subscribe
notification bell and share this with
your friends because that's the real way
we win
but let's get to the news most of you
may have seen the reports from reuters
this morning
anti-fascist protesters vandalized
buildings in portland and seattle
they report anti-government and
anti-fascist protesters in portland and
seattle vandalized a democratic party
office
and other buildings and scuffled with
police on wednesday
protesting against president joe biden's
inauguration
people dressed in black and with their
faces covered broke windows in the glass
door at the democratic party of oregon
business office in portland
spray painting an anarchist symbol over
the party sign video posted on social
media showed
we don't want biden we want revenge for
police murders imperialist wars and
fascist massacres
read a banner they marched under the new
democratic president was sworn in on
wednesday
urging unity and restoration after
republican donald trump's divisive
tenure donald trump was so divisive when
uh you know joe biden
started his presidency by saying this
country is being torn apart by white
supremacists and nativists and
sounded an awful lot like he was calling
the other half of the country
deplorables if you know what i mean so
spare me this rhetoric about you know
biden being the one who truly does want
unity i'll respect him trying to tone
things down
but at least i can say this he used and
abused and is tossing out
antifa the democrats defended him what
was that was that meme you mentioned
luke
in toy story there's a scene where the
toys are being thrown out and right now
there's a meme going around with the
toys being blm and antifa
and uh the the big you know the the
child in there being of course joe biden
throwing them away
throwing him in the garbage the real
test though is when and if these antifa
members get arrested is his campaign
going to continue to bail them out of
prison because that's how you really
know if he's done with him or not
yes because kamala harris also was
raising funds for
a lot of the rioters that broke the law
and and also what's really interesting
is you know we had the mainstream media
hyperbolically screaming about the
potential of violence at all the 50
capitals that's coming our way
they were they were screaming about it
at the highest decibel of annoyance
possible
but now we do have violence but there's
a different kind of violence that just
gets totally swept under the rug no
one's talking about this
like what's going on here it's
ridiculous conservatives
are aware of the double standard and i'm
sorry but saying there's a double
standard is pointless
at right now and the republicans are
more than happy to
stand to stand to attention for the
democrats to help them
pretend to provide balance to their
agenda so mitch mcconnell with his
you know turtle smile well i'm trying to
look rightful for draubar
and there you go that's it he stands up
he claps and cheers
all these republicans are clapping and
cheering yay the democrats won and
there's no one actually fighting for
conservatives
no maybe a couple people and it's not
even necessarily conservatives but like
just against the left you have this faux
resistance
so what's happening now in my opinion
and it would it could have gone either
way you know i thought joe biden was
going to throw them a little bit more
red meat maybe throw them a bone
to placate them but i guess these people
just want chaos
so it's really funny because when we saw
them destroying the windows at the
democratic party hq
these viral videos on twitter someone
tweeted
that it was just like what the us
normally does
funding terrorists in the middle east
who then eventually turn on us and start
causing damage
to ryden funny so the mujahideen for
instance and then al qaeda
so they they get these antifa people to
go around smashing everything up
they say oh no look at trump's america
and now that it's biden's america
and they go around smashing things up
it's like yeah they're at fault
there was tear gas deployed in major u.s
cities hold on hold on hold on
this was joe biden's gestapo stomping
out
anti-racist and and pro-freedom
protesters anti-fascists anti-fascists
they were just trying to help
and joe biden's gestapo stomp them out
which is again a 180 degree
turn from where we were six months ago
where tom cotton
wrote a new york times editorial please
piece talking about how we need
to send in the military to deal with
black lives matter
huge controversy the new york times
editor got fired because of
allowing an opinion but forced to resign
yes or i should say he resigned in shame
as i say potato potato you know what
went on you know what happened there and
now there's it's a big
controversy it's not even it's not even
even talked about
but i remember seeing one of the antifa
signs saying we don't want to bide in
administration we want vengeance yes i
have a picture i believe
yes and it's a pretty visceral picture
but people need to understand
the larger base of antifa are not big
biden supporters i don't think they ever
were
in the first place they weren't yeah and
so this is one of the issues i had with
high profile conservative personalities
that would say like anti-fuzz the
militant wing of the democrat party and
i'm like no they hate democrats
they will punch a liberal in the face
but democrats were eager to defend them
as long as they were making trump look
bad
yep dangerous dude and now well what are
they going to do look at the middle east
with obama and isis
it's like it's perfectly on on uh uh you
know
it's on brand on brand there you go yeah
it's exactly their game like when you
use an evil demon
i'm sorry i'm i'm sorry uh i'm sorry i
just saw this
we are ungovernable uh-huh literally
technically correct there's you know
what i think there's
there's anarchists like these people who
are more like
some kind of rabid skunk
you're like you know cause the kungs are
like all black you know i mean like
they're wearing all black
and then they like they run around and
you can't do anything with them because
they're rabid
and that's the kind of anarchist they
are and you have people like luke who
are like i would like to use bitcoin to
buy guns
and that's the other kind of anarchist i
guess non-aggression principle and
allowing people to
you know transact peacefully in a way
that benefits them without transgressing
on anyone's personal liberty or
sovereignty or freedom
did i say buy bitcoin with guns because
i guess that would still work
yeah yeah yeah here's a gun one bitcoin
please people do that
that that has happened there's many
interesting aggregate
aggregate transactions that happen all
the time i guess you would be selling
the gun for bitcoin
it's a common transaction in galt's cult
happens all the time
yeah we don't want biden we want revenge
for police murders imperialist wars and
fascist massacres and you know if you
ask them they probably can't tell you
what that means
yeah somebody made a statement most of
those people are foot soldiers just
enraged
angry because they're not making any
money they can see the the economy
spiraling out of control and they're
that's about
they can't level with them they think
they can see it they don't know
no they want money printed they're the
ones who are like print
our money and give it to us it's life
but prices are going up
like everyone sees that yeah but it's
because of them
it's because it's it's like could you
imagine someone being like we should put
peanut butter in the gas tank and you're
like that'll break the car and then when
the car breaks
more peanut butter the car is breaking
i'm so angry and you're like you put
peanut butter in the gas tank dude
machine doesn't work that way but also
another interesting facet to understand
here
you know they're going to eat their own
they're going to be fighting each other
as i was
saying you know a long time on this show
but another one is you know a lot of
them think that they were promised
police reform
and that's nowhere to be seen a part of
this new biden administration not that
i've seen
i haven't seen any clutter or
conversations or talk about any kind of
reforming of the police or authorities
and that's kind of their meaning
they put the militant prosecutor as vp
yeah yeah yeah yeah yep they put 25 000
troops in dc they started putting up
thank you police officer signs all over
dc didn't pelosi want uh quote crew uh
manned
mccain guns man the capital crew and
machine gun
gendered language in that situation it
was threatening to them
right but what this justice department
is more than likely going to be doing is
going to your neighborhood police
departments and hitting them with
lawsuits because there are allegations
to somebody getting mistreated when the
cop was just doing his own job
so that's a real fear in terms of how
they're going to affect policing
where you live in your neighborhoods by
interfering with the way your local
police operations are
and also with the attorney general right
we recently saw in new york with the
attorney general actually going after
the nypd for their handling
of blm protesters so that's another case
that's happening
they they exacerbated the problem a
problem that
i mean luke you and i have been
complaining about for a decade now
since back when when the black bloc
anarchist types were going around
smashing stuff
there was a moment where a dude was
stalking me and then physically attacked
me and luke
grabbed his mask you know well me and
matt intervened because i saw him kind
of going after you and i was like okay
let me stay
close to tim because i see they're going
to try to attack him and that's when
they kind of jumped at you for
live streaming behind you and as soon as
they got behind you me and matt kind of
jumped in and
you know where was take care of that
situation new york nine years ago
nine years ago and uh i mean what else
did people expect if you if you
normalize violence politically what did
you think was going to
happen and now the democrats the bidens
they have a
huge huge situation that's very
explosive right in their hands
that they cultivated themselves let's
let's jump to the story you mentioned
luke we got here from the daily caller
ken cuccinelli claims pelosi asked for
crew manned machine guns in washington
i believe it i i kind of believe it but
we'll let's read
acting deputy homeland security
secretary ken cuccinelli told fox news
the story
tuesday that house speaker nancy pelosi
asked for crew-manned machine guns to be
part of security forces in washington dc
ahead of president-elect joe biden's
inauguration cuccinelli and anchor
martha mccallum were discussing the
presence of 25 000 national guard troops
the nation's capital
after pro-trump rioters stormed the u.s
capitol building january 6.
a division cucinelli said responding to
mccallum's assertion
that the number of troops is greater
than the number in afghanistan and iraq
you have a division the last up of
thousands of these troops was requested
by the speaker
through the capitol police she even
wanted crew-manned machine guns in
washington
that was rejected because there's simply
no use for that in a security
arrangement
for a civilian undertaking just so some
of this has gone beyond
any legitimate security need cuccinelli
defended the troops as disciplined and
professional
and said they will perform as expected
but added that the state capitol
building
buildings are also important to defend
the world is not about washington he
said
it's supposed to be about everywhere
else which is what the department of
homeland security tries to keep secure
the acting dhs deputy secretary
confirmed that threats of individual
attacks in different places
are also absolutely a problem before
criticizing those who focus
only on dc he says at the same time
where was the concern for the rest of
america
congressmen aren't more important than
any other american it's a good point
boom and everyone in this country should
should be kept safe and that's what the
department of homeland security has
endeavored to do
through this entire difficult year crew
manned machine guns what would that be
like full auto 50 bmg
there's a team where one's holding it
the other one has to carry the ammo and
make sure the belt yeah the belt theater
was that what would that be 50 bmg
uh i guess theoretically there's many
different calibers yeah yeah you could
do something
yes so uh i'd like to imagine they were
like mounting 50 bmg
just like like like nancy pelosi wanted
just like
to like if a human being gets hit one by
one of those things they explode right
like a red mist
i wouldn't want to see that i don't i
think a lot of soldiers
dark humor uh oh but i want to make a
point i'm just trying to drive home how
insane it sounds
but here's the thing in 2017 when there
were thousands of people in dc
rioting and smashing everything and
starting fires they organized that
protest for hillary clinton
not for donald trump the original plan
was that hillary clinton was going to be
inaugurated and they were going to go in
riot
trump won and they said well we're still
going to riot so i wonder if
the real fear here wasn't the the
specter of the far
right which typically doesn't do
anything but that they knew
like we saw in portland and seattle and
denver and a few other places
antifa would have come out in dc and
destroyed everything were it not for the
national guard yep
and i remember being there in dc you
were there too i think yeah
we all got pepper sprayed i was
temporarily arrested and then talked
more out of it with my press credentials
but it was a wild
crazy day with a lot of property
destruction we were we were walking down
the street during the riot while we were
running with the riot
and then the police set up a line you
charged through it
and then i getting pepper sprayed
heavily they sprayed you like they
sprayed
their faces he ran through the line yeah
and then i went into the doorway of this
building
and then because this is how it works
everyone followed me
and so then i was smashed up against the
door by a bunch of antifa and they were
and some of the people were nice they
gave me uh uh the milk of magnesia or
whatever mailbox from my for the pepper
spray
i i was told three times by the
supervisor that i was arrested and not
free to go yep
but eventually a local news crew had
their boss had called saying you better
not arrest
our crew so when he pulled out this crew
i reminded the
lieutenant that i was like hey i talked
to you look here's my press card and he
was like come on
and a bunch of journalists got pulled
out now here's the funny thing about
this
i get pulled out and i tweet just got
arrested they released me before you
know being taken
i was there for like an hour or two and
some other journalists did get arrested
and they were so mad they were tweeting
like i got arrested
i'm like dude one guy was screaming at
the top of his lungs at the cops
you mother effort you can arrest me and
i was like i'm terribly sorry officer
i'm a journalist
do your job on you know here's my press
card just come and talk to me when you
get a chance yeah and that was it i
remember seeing the kettle and i'm like
oh my god they're going to kill and
arrest everyone and there's a wall
of pepper spray and they were spraying
it and i was like i'm just gonna run
right through it i got hit really hard
there was another female reporter
who just made up and said i'm pregnant
i'm pregnant so i was like i'm going i'm
going through this and then luckily
yeah they pulled her out but back to the
point of machine guns that
nancy pelosi wants she's essentially
saying protection
for me but not for thee these are
anti-gun
anti-second amendment individuals who
don't believe in you having the right
for personal protection
but they want machine guns for
themselves are you kidding me
you've got the nfa you can't make was it
how does it work you can't make a
machine gun you can't have a machine
you could only have machine guns within
a certain year so so pretty much machine
guns are only available for the super
rich that could afford them because
there's a limited supply within a
certain year that you can
uh it could could have them so they're
grandfathered in there's few remaining
uh and the few that are are only
available to people who could spend
thirty forty fifty thousand dollars for
government or the military
yes so nancy pelosi is leading the
charge to take away
your right to have these this protection
but she wants
of all things if she said i would like
the national guard to be armed with
assault rifles i'd be like yeah
well of course the politicians get to
carry guns the politicians get to have
security
but she she well but think about it
machine guns but they're loving but
they're
practical when you're talking about crew
men machine guns during inaugurations
during big events when there's crowds
this is the least tactical weapon that
you could have especially in big cities
with big crowds because you're going to
mow down a whole bunch of innocent
civilians
standing in the way that don't deserve
to be killed civilian buildings yeah so
it's just absolutely illogical it's not
listening
to thinking by nancy pelosi it's because
they don't understand that full auto
isn't tactical they think we have to ban
full semi-automatic weapons which for
one that they've actually said that
means nothing
when they say i remember at the march
for our lives people were like you know
no one needs a full fully automatic
weapon and i'd tell them like
well you can't buy one and nobody has
one except for like these really rare
grandfathered and old
and it's never used in a crime here yeah
nobody's carrying around
a light machine gun in their truck or
whatever to like like it's like it's a
movie or something
right but that's what these people think
so here's what people don't realize
now i'm sure people can correct me if
i'm wrong but what what you should be
worried about my understanding is that a
semi-auto is actually way more dangerous
than a full auto for a deranged killer
because they'll spray off all their ammo
and miss and then click click click
whereas with samurai they can go one two
very you know
calm and precise more importantly when
you have the military it's sometimes
better to do select
to to do you know semi-auto or burst
fire than full auto
nancy pelosi saying crew man to machine
guns shows they don't actually know
how to operate a weapon why and what
kind of weapon you would need
for this certain circumstance so she's
should never be president
she doesn't understand military she she
wanted the dod was it to go
take do a coup against trump like two
weeks ago she asked them to strip trump
from the chain of commerce
well she has no considerations for the
citizens of washington d.c
think about it it's much more nefarious
than that i think because
this um this was in reaction to what
happened on the sixth okay
say what you about the six but we're in
a country here where
pretty much anybody can get a firearm
pretty much anybody can get an ar an
assault weapon anything like that
i don't remember seeing a whole lot of
protesters
brandishing much less firing firearms in
the sixth
so if this was a preparation for a
reaction similar this reaction was in
preparation for what they saw in the six
which is calling for is automatic
military weapons to be used
on an unarmed population these
this is what she thinks of the country
of the people of the citizens
she is content with having 50 caliber
military-grade weapons
aimed at them and ready we we added the
50 caliber part oh
okay all right all right all right let's
just you're right you've got
room and machine guns yes guns that
require multiple people to operate them
let's
go with that that's what she thinks of
us in the country
i'm surprised she didn't set up
landmines all over the capitol building
i mean
it would make more sense with with the
you know actual tactical
defensive positioning rather than mowing
people down with automatic machine guns
so
it's but it's beyond the people could
you imagine look look i was i've been
i've been to ukraine i know i mentioned
ukraine
because it's this place i've been to and
there are still buildings
riddled with bullet holes from world war
ii and
cold war conflict and so i'm walking
down the street we went to the mall we
get food
and then my friend is like oh look at
that building see all those holes yeah
that's this machine gun fire
and i'm like they never fixed it no i'm
like wow i mean it's a poor country so
they're kind of just like
what are we gonna do about it right and
remember under her leadership in the
leader
of her party we had members of in our
navy in hostile ports being ordered not
to be armed not to have
uh ammunition in their firearms taking
their naval vessels into hostile ports
and they were attacked and many of them
died from that
yet here at this inauguration she wants
what what's the situation with the naval
guy i haven't heard of this what
happened oh yeah it was under the
previous democrat administration
um they were prevented from having uh
armed weapons as they went into several
um you know hostile uh uh ports
and there was one case where that
actually ended up an attack ship came in
they were unable to respond to it
and it detonated and killed a bunch of
american sailors do you know where that
was
i'm sure we can google it or look it up
i can't recall somewhere in the middle
east that was that was pelosi's
well it was that was when she was in
congress and her democratic party's
leadership
they had the white house at the time so
there you go you can see what these
people what these politicians think of
the people
and what they would do to them but
that's a good point man the people who
stormed the capital
many of them were just bewildered and
befuddled walking into open doors
some of them were violent and aggressive
but they were i think the worst we saw
was crowbars
yeah well i think there was one video
with one guy brandishing what looked
like a firearm with
within his shirt but i don't think he
took it out and was waving it around but
i think it's fair to say that the
magnitude of the threat was
widely exaggerated for political
purposes and political powers and also
for the media for
ratings views clicks with their kind of
fear-mongering sensationalism
that drove the headlines in and now we
have some violence happening they don't
care about it because it's the wrong
thing
hold on hold on
biden was made to look really bad today
all right uh when antifa
was was trending on twitter and settled
in portland and uh
well they had to take action so we got
this tweet from andy know breaking
twitter has suspended
several prominent antifa accounts the
base brooklyn is one of them
the base is an extremist bookstore in
brooklyn new york that has been used as
an anti-for training center
16 800 followers gone
we also have mf m the jewish worker 30
000 followers
gone revolutionary abolitionist movement
11 000 400 followers
gone and rev abolition nyc gone and i
think these are just a few
that andy has highlighted i'm sure
there's a lot more and this is
well like we mentioned earlier they're
throwing away what they don't need
anymore
it's making them look bad they need to
get rid of it and uh
you know what i'll say this if they were
advocating violence
if they were organizing violence ban
them get rid of them
if they were just tweeting stupid
opinions then i still think the
censorship is bad
i don't care if it's the left or the
right but you know when the biggest
problems with all of the censorship
stuff is
there was there's a left-wing podcast
that got nuked on on youtube i'm not
gonna name
them and immediately you know i see i
see the libertarians i see the free
speech advocates the anti-sjw's all
defending them saying hey hey reinstate
them
but then what happens when it's say you
know count dankula gets mass demonetized
they go ha ha
serves you right but i'm a private
business
that's a problem you know when someone
when you get when you get a person like
count dankela
who will act with honor and integrity
and stand up for principle
and his adversaries will not we are all
at a disadvantage when we're fair
and respect people and their rights to
free speech that being said
these people i believe were pro i
wouldn't be surprised if they were
organizing actual violence
you know they like to point to right
wingers and they say i see this on
reddit all the time
well maybe you shouldn't send death
threats to people and they wouldn't have
deleted parlor and it's like dude
there was i think 60 posts out of
hundreds of thousands
just in like an appear like an hour
period that were violent
all right i'm sorry i should say there
were probably millions of posts and 60
all together that were considered to be
like harsh death threats so they
nuked the entire company come on man
that doesn't make sense
twitter is loaded with extremist
propaganda and calls for violence and
it's protected
so if you were to tell me that people on
parlor were sending you know death
threats whatever i'd be like oh yeah
it's a good thing they were banning them
but that's not everybody and if you tell
me antifa was doing it i'd be like
yeah are they going to ban them and then
they're going to cry follow and they're
going to start saying
we're the free speech activists to
defend our free speech the one thing i
really love about all this stuff is
when i see the tweets on the leftist and
they're like where are all the free
speech warriors now
to to complain about the censorship of
those criticizing israel
and i'm like bro we've all been
defending your free speech to the entire
time and when it happens we always speak
up about it
and then when it happens to us they
laugh
so what do you do i even remember
arguing
arguing with them years ago when people
were being banned
uh independent media people on the right
and they were celebrating it i'm like
you guys don't understand
the hammer is going to come after you
very
very soon here it is it's only going to
get worse and and this is what happens
when you
cheer on for a sm for a few
small select individuals to have the
ultimate power of controlling speech
it's a huge power it's going to be used
and abused
if you're standing in the way of the
cogs of the machines if you're not in
the right position if you're not
reiterating the right talking points at
the right time
you're going to be axed no matter who
you are and it's coming everywhere
i think it was glenn greenwald who said
it best i think this was
i think it's his quote that if there's
any group of people that fails to learn
from past mistakes it's liberals
advocating for censorship
because it always recoils back on them
and it's true for antifa now getting
nuked they were all cheering for it well
goodbye when you talk about censorship
and antifa violence it's like a demon
that is like
free me and i will destroy your enemies
yeah you're like
that all all you have to do is release
me from these chains
trust me yes and you're like that's mark
zuckerberg and then you release the
demon he kills your enemies and then he
tries and then he kills you
it's like it's like you know you ever
see aladdin
when when jafar wishes he's a genie and
then they did
the the uh the part two for like
straight to home dvd jafar is a genie
now and he's like wish me free it's like
yeah you're evil and if we unleash this
you're gonna hurt everybody
but you know what man some people don't
care they don't know no no
you know what it is it's the one ring
it's it's it's watching a lot of lord of
the rings lately
auntie was boromir right and he's like
censorship is a gift
we should wield it against our enemies
you can't control it
no one can that's exactly what happened
and they didn't get it
and now they're getting nuked but i
think a lot of them is ignorance so we
can you know
just spread the knowledge about the
dangerous censorship that helps a lot
not everyone's
malicious a lot of people are ignorant i
saw a cartoon today where uh it's four
guys in a boat and two guys are on one
end
bailing the boat out because there's a
leak at the other end and the other two
guys at the other end of the boat are
like haha well i'm glad you know this
isn't affecting us
oh cause it's raised up right exactly
yeah they're like floating in the boat
sinking
yeah yeah that's the the world they seek
to create but
i'll tell you what's interesting about
this so uh i'll just show you this real
quick this is literally what antifa is
doing
today you know we we mentioned this in
the previous segment we don't want biden
we want
revenge and there's what looks like is
that it is that an ak
yeah it looks like an ak i could be
wrong um
but this uh the organization the base is
is based in new york they have a
public-facing website all this
information is readily available in
public they have their open hours
they say the base is an anarchist
political center in bushwick brooklyn
committed to the dissemination of
revolutionary left and anarchist ideas
and organizing
now on their website it's very you know
innocuous right
well project veritas actually did an
expose
i don't i don't know if i've actually
actually had the full expose well here's
an opinion piece about it or something
where they had footage from inside where
they were doing
combat training basically you know the
self-defense training you're allowed to
do self
self defense training totally totally
acceptable i took kung fu class once
that's right i did yeah we had to fight
with the sticks it was really cool
long time ago as no no no it's called
something else because there's two of
them and you hold them like that
and we did this like they do this really
fast you know fighting stuff
so that's fine but there is an issue
when you've got
advocacy for violence when you've got
evidence that these
these groups in new york have been
violent and they're teaching people
about revolutionary ideas
and they hold extremist views and then
they train for violence
you add all those things together and i
wouldn't be surprised if they're posting
really really bad stuff
it's gonna get them banned wouldn't it
be good though if we knew what they
posted that they got banned for yeah
like i've maybe it was innocuous maybe
it was something that um
crosses the line i mean we have no idea
it's always the mystery with these guys
there's no transparency in the banning
process
and that that is a problem and that's
why i typically am opposed to it no
matter what
well but i guess you got to draw the
line if they're saying like go do a
thing you know what i mean so we should
at least
know what they said and and to have full
transparency and accountability from
these big tech networks that are
literally
having the most important power in the
world destroying
anything that that could be made up
it's such a catch-20 i don't know if
it's catch-22 or it's just a
hard situation because if they said
something that's going to radicalize
people they want to
prevent people from seeing it but if
they prevent people from seeing it then
we can't verify
that what they did was wrong exactly the
problem is that they shouldn't get to
choose
what is going to radicalize someone
every idea should be held equally valid
unless it's
explicitly calling for violence against
someone so every idea should be out well
and that and if it was actually calling
for violence it's not that's not
actually
legally protected speech exactly either
i mean because the law is pretty clear
in fact um actually if i can jump in
here and say something about uh
this problem i actually came here
tonight with the solution
to this problem oh yes evolution a
solution to solutions
we don't talk about that all we do is
complain
it is i agree with you it's much easier
to complain but but i have the solution
i brought it with me
um to tech censorship to de-platforming
to getting blacklisted by financial
firms and it's very simple we have to
sort of look
where do we have strength still because
you know the senate's gone the house is
gone
it's in the control progressives um we
don't know where the supreme court is
but where we still have a lot of
allies and people supporting us in fact
in the majority of the state
legislatures
so i believe that the solution is state
level state legislation that prevents
the state
and any government within the state
that's counties cities etc
from engaging in business with the
social networks that censor
with tech companies that de-platform
with um
with financial institutions that
blacklist people because look we kind of
agree we're all on the side that it's
your company you run the social network
you can decide who's on it and who isn't
right but you're not
entitled to tax money paid
by people who you are deplatforming whom
you're getting fired
whom you're throwing off your service
and blacklisting and taking away their
bank accounts
so the solution is for citizens you guys
out there
to lobby your state legislatures to say
we're not going to give any business to
any one of these companies
that does this we're going to divest our
pension funds our any day funds from
companies
that engage in this behavior and either
if this if you're going to get a
government contract
you're going to embrace the first
amendment you're not going to
de-platform people for legal speech
constitutionally protected um uh
political activity
or gainful employment you're so the way
to get where we're going is basically to
get these state governments on board
and one of two things gonna happen okay
one two three five states
agree to this type of legislation either
the amazons the twitters the facebooks
are gonna say okay okay we are not gonna
sense your legal speech
or they're gonna say ask screw you guys
we're going to do what we want and
suddenly
there's a space for companies that do
embrace that to go after those
government contracts
to go after that money and that's how we
create this
parallel alternate ecosystem of
financial companies social media
and technical companies who embrace the
first amendment this is these government
contracts would be the seed money to
create this ecosystem
so basically the bottom line is the
state of south carolina texas oklahoma
all these states where we could
potentially pass this legislation say to
amazon to twitter to facebook look
you're not getting another penny from us
or to citibank you're not going to kick
these people off your platform because
you disagree with their
political ideas and continue to do
business with us so they'll have to make
a choice and them saying no creates a
space for these new companies to emerge
that do embrace the first amendment
what kind of money do states send uh the
way of
amazon and facebook well marketing
budgets is one thing on the socials now
that's not that's not particularly huge
but which is much more significant
is their pension funds and rainy day
funds being invested in these companies
as well as so many government services
are dependent on contractors that use
services like amazon web services
and those other companies that uh that
discriminate the kick parlor off right
so you know if just south carolina or
just oklahoma did it
maybe it wouldn't get their attention
but you get like half the states in the
country doing those are billions and
billions and billions of dollars
that either they're gonna have to change
their policies to accept or give up
and that becomes the fuel for their new
competitors who embrace the first
amendment
to to get that seed money so they can
grow and compete against them
and look like i said they're entitled to
run their platforms i
suppose how they want but they're not
entitled to tax dollars paid for by me
whose rights they're denying whose
rights of free expression and political
activity
and gainful employment they're deploying
they're denying so this is how we fight
back and
um i guess i'm going to plug this but
look ahead america we're going to train
people
next wednesday online as many as 3 000
people on how to do grassroots lobbying
how to lobby your legislature to get
them to pass legislation like this that
says look
facebook may kick you off but they're
not going to get in your tax money
for advertising or marketing aws may
kick your parlor off but they're not
going to get any contracts for running
the state's medicare medicaid programs
if they're going to de-platform you so
the moment there is a legitimate legal
challenge saying
i was unjustly removed from this
platform due to my protected speech
then the state seizes ceases all
contracts and tax expenditures going to
these companies well it'll be like a
year period where they get to
disentangle from any state any uh any
entity that does not agree to
basically fulfill you know allow people
to have free speech free legal speech
without censoring it
and there's you know it's every state
has its different legal peculiarities
but we have like these are the policy
objectives very clear and simple
you get a state legislature to turn them
into the state's legislative council
it becomes legislation it goes through
hearings amendments etc
but this this is how we fight back why
don't we just have the state
legislatures pass laws saying you can't
ban people for legal speech
well they tried that in florida i
believe it didn't go anywhere but why
not just
actually get it done because this is i
think easier because the state can
control who it does money
does contracts with you may recall the
state of california banned all
travel to other states that did not like
support bathroom laws the federal
government other states also have
writers for all their contracts
that force them to accept rules that are
not part of civil rights legislation but
sort of extend it
so this is common in government
contracting and very powerful tool for
reform
and it's just a lot easier than saying
hey social networks can't ban it because
then
you know it becomes a federal matter
whereas the states control who they're
going to spend with who they're not
going to spend with yeah we saw poland
recently propose
legislation that would heavily fine
social media companies for censoring
legal speech
so that's also another aspect of it but
this is interesting because many silicon
valley companies are looking to leave
california that tax-filled amazing place
that has a lot of homeless people
because of the unlivable conditions
these companies are looking to
reposition themselves so this could be
an opportunity to
to have local jurisdictions kind of step
up
i think i mean do you have high hopes of
the organ of this being able to be
organized and
what other ties do local jurisdictions
have with big tech
that could be affected here well look
all of these big tech companies
have offices in every state capital why
it's because they're going after state
government contracts
these are hundreds of billions of
trillions of dollars in state
city county spending and this matters
and again it's going to have one or two
outcomes
either they're going to forego billions
of dollars in revenue
billions of dollars that will instead go
to their competitors
brand new competitors which they hate
and fear
or they're going to have to rely and say
okay we're going to permit legal speech
we're not going to kick people off our
platform for
you know you've got banks saying that
we're going to stop doing business with
firearms manufacturers and
you know if it's your thing you know
marijuana farms right because
well this would prevent that or at least
say the state is not going to accept
payments from these banks or do
transactions through these banks if they
ban legal it's very it's very simple
whereas
it when you start banning like the
behavior or you say a social network
can't ban legal speech
you get to interstate commerce issues
and you know this maybe that company's
located another state you're going to
cough internet traffic it becomes very
complicated
whereas this is very clean cut and i
have high hopes because look
we've got a lot of people with a lot of
energy who want to do something and want
to make a difference and are fed up with
this problem
becoming us a grassroots lobbyist
becoming an
activist this is what the left has done
for so long and they've had
tremendous success with it because
they're patient with themselves
the time it took and because they were
determined they didn't give up
i know that there are at least a third
to half of the states in this country
that would eagerly pass some form of
this legislation it's just that it has
to get
pushed and nothing moves in politics
unless it pushes dependent on
these folks out here to to allow my
organization look at america
to organize them to guide them and to
train them on how to do this and how to
actually make it happen because we can
talk all day about all the problems in
the world
and we've but we've got enough talkers
tim does a great job we don't need more
talkers
we need more doers we need more people
doing it and lobbying the state
legislature and getting in their faces
on it and the one thing that we're
you know we're trying to do especially
is building culture so i've often talked
about i'm just a guy complaining on the
internet
and so that's why for a while we've been
talking about doing this vlog where
we'll start
actually doing things and that's why
we're working on timcast.com because i'm
like i can't just keep sitting here
complaining on youtube it's ridiculous
it's okay to be a talker sometimes but
there's gonna be backers there's balance
right there is about so it's gonna be
yin yang we're gonna do the stuff where
we're like this is bad stuff and we're
gonna be like let's make things and have
fun and inspire people to do stuff and
get them
into you know i'll put it this way we
talk about it all the time
the left will play video games and
they'll live stream twitch they go on
twitch they'll play video games which
i'm doing later tonight by the way
but we'll talk more about it later while
they're playing video games
and these young people are watching
minecraft or whatever they're talking
leftist politics
and it works and then i won't twitch now
because
because you know twitch is dominated by
the left they ban people for even a
moderate
opinion you're gone so we need is we
need young people who are looking at
cool interesting things getting cheered
on be it skateboarding or music
or you know firing guns at the range
just fun stuff demolition ranch style
stuff
the kids get excited by it and then you
know what do they see in the background
a gadsden flag
so then when they try and claim the
gadsden flag as a symbol of white
supremacy they go
no ah that skateboarder guy's got one of
those that's crazy
i won't believe it i like that guy he's
cool when they tried claiming that
pewdiepie was a white supremacist or
whatever because he said some stupid
words and made some stupid jokes
all these kids were like no he's not
you're lying
and then all of a sudden these little
kids who are like the media is lying
they're lies and then i remember the
story jake tapper said his son calls him
fake news
think about how powerful it is they
realized this this freaked them out
and then all of a sudden the censorship
went nuts because several years ago
jake tapper said when my kids get kid
get mad gets mad at me he calls me fake
news
wow where does that kid hear that from
yeah he heard it from the likes of
pewdiepie they went after pewdiepie
hard he heard it on youtube they started
going after youtubers and purging these
channels and getting rid of them
so you got to find a way to share your
ideas
have them be peripheral to what you do
but inspire and and create and then
honestly what you're talking about as
well the legislative angle
but i will say as much as i think you
are 100 correct and people need to focus
on that too
one of the problems i think is
conservatives go fro go at a legislative
angle
whereas the left owns the culture and
then because they own the culture
they control the kids grow up and
they're always left now now gen z is the
first generation to be
slightly more right than yeah because of
the internet
like hollywood is very left i was in
that but it's not because of the
internet it's because it's part of
youtube
and we balanced it out a lot in the very
far left in the 90s
but it's not because of the internet
it's actually this is actually really
obvious
in the 2000s there were several studies
done on the political ideology and
children and they found that
conservatives were having 2.01 children
and liberals are having 1.7 children
what happens when you add 20 years from
when those studies were done
you now have the next generation gen z
leaning a little bit more conservative
why
conservatives had kids more often than
liberals did it's actually very very
simple
now youtube internet all that stuff
plays a role for sure
if you're not inspiring young people
then you end up with kids
snitching on their parents because their
parents were seen at you know the
capital or whatever which is what
happened
and like a liberal dad doesn't
necessarily have a liberal kid like
tapper for instance super liberal his
kid's
apparently not that kid sounds like
awakened so
i i found hollywood dominated culture in
the 90s 2000s i mean honestly way back
to the since the 30s
and they're just you have to shut your
mouth
and play the game to live in that
industry they will fire you in a
heartbeat
and as soon as the internet came around
i realized dude i can say whatever i
want and i can make a living
this is like next level well yeah
i mean that's why they went after
pewdiepie and joe rogan and so many
other kind of cultural institutions that
weren't regurgitating their talking
points and they were providing
entertainment
that wasn't uh propaganda that wasn't
brainwashing that wasn't disinformation
you turn on all the mainstream media
crap whether it's hollywood movies
tv series there's so much subliminal
trash and garbage and messaging in there
that it's absolutely ridiculous it's
unwatchable for people who know what's
going on who know the narrative who know
the agenda
who know the talking points seeing it
again and again portrayed in so many
different ways
it's it's essentially brainwashing
according to a lot of individuals
especially when you look at the deeper
involvement of the state
with hollywood and their active
involvement with writing scripts it's
it's a big it's a big game that they
want to take out anyone who's not
involved in it like i was at
i actually am the rare right winger who
has a
master in fine arts from columbia
university and i can tell you that my
time there
the ideological persuasion of the vast
majority of those was
far far far left or don't really care
about politics but go along to get along
with the left
and you think about who's the producers
directors writers as you're saying
in hollywood right like almost every
show you can get on netflix disney plus
who et cetera
if you look at those writers and what
they have they look at you know middle
america
patriotic american they they look at it
with disgust and disdain and they
and almost i would say almost a hatred
and that's who basically anytime you put
your kid in front of the television
that's who's
feeding them and you know this is why i
think there's a shift is because
you know who's really competing with
netflix right now and uh
you know mainstream channels on
television and primetime tv
are is video games his call of duty is
twitch
streamers those that's the competition
and that's an environment that doesn't
lend itself so easily to
subtle left-wing manipulation and
cultural brainwashing twitch is
dominated entirely by
far far left hardcore tankies and
full-blown communists and if you look at
the previous call of duty not this one
that just came out the previous one had
so much crazy insane russian propaganda
syrian chemical warfare and wmds all of
it pushing of course the mainline
neoconservative messaging of we need
more war we need to fight russia we need
to stop assad
all of it was directly involved in it on
such a sickening level it was it was
crazy to watch i live straight into that
game
because i was surprised to see all the
pro wars sure but
it's not it's i want to make a point
though it's not quite as convincing
and and uh brainwashing as say any
typical left-wing show in the 90s if
you're just sitting there shooting
people
in call of duty or something i'm just
saying it's not it's it's not as
in call of duty you literally were a
child that was
uh suffering a gas attack by the
character that was clearly bashar
al-assad and you were a child
trying to sneak away from the russians
that were killing your mom in front of
you
so that type of level of propaganda holy
cow i mean
it has an impact on children who are
just thrown would you rather a child do
that or watch
um gossip girl well games are more
more kind of immersive people put
themselves in games and even put on
diapers
because they don't want to leave this
that kind of entertainment realm in
japan
listen there's literally a.a meetings in
japan against gaming sure sure i got no
problem with gaming
but you mentioned twitch and i think i'm
pretty sure the biggest twitch streamer
is like a hardcore socialist i guess
advocating for violence
in a video game in a video game is what
he does he'll be like
he'll he'll literally call to action and
go in a video game
because he knows it's like it's not a
legal defense what do you thinks it is
and so you guys should go fill in the
blank we need to go do this right now
in a video game yeah oh wow it doesn't
work if they wanted
if they want to go after them they would
but it's ridiculous i agree with you
matt
i think i think it's the movies and tv
are uber brainwashing and when the
game the gamer has control there's no
writer like the games have been written
and do have a plot and like call of duty
was extreme propaganda
especially the new one is extreme
russian like hate propaganda
that's the new one the one before the
new one i haven't i haven't played i
haven't played the new one i stopped
i stopped poisoning my mind with that
content um but most
a lot of most games are kind of uh kind
of neutral
the platform it's just a game you play
them it's mostly multiplayer like
i don't know most games are pro gun
sure yes first person shooter is a
freaking
genre it's not that's not that like
first person shooter
grand theft auto do you remember that
christchurch shooting
in in what was it new zealand that they
were live
streaming it with a head cam and then
people like overlaid it
and made it look like a doom game and
like we're getting kill counts and stuff
that's messed up yeah first possible
shooting is is highly
training us to become killers it sounds
like we're gonna get a lan party going
here because we've got the deaths
we have high speed think about even
going back to mario
mario literally jumped on and crushed
turtles
and he ate mushrooms bro and he punched
bricks
so there's like video games
like this like violence is a strong
strong component there's a big
there was always a big push from
leftists to make what they called
walking simulators
games where the the like the goal was
not to do anything violent
because they were like these sjws were
complaining why is every video game
gonna be violent or whatever but i'll
tell you
these kids are growing up playing you
name a video game and like most of the
big ones are guns
like destiny right you play destiny it's
like you're a space guardian
and guns you shoot aliens with guns
lots of different kinds and rocket
launchers and first-person shooters man
but also third person shooters the
division
what's the cyberpunk it's all about
beating punching and shooting
i was playing red dead redemption last
night with adam kriegler soy jesus shout
out we'll be playing again later on
tonight and um
i was like after i got done playing i
was like how come there are no native
americans that just like
attack you and that you just mow down
and i think that
they specifically chose it's like the
old west but they specifically chose not
to introduce that kind of violence into
the game
there's a lot of violence oh that game
is like but there's no natives i haven't
seen any natives you can like kill
somebody and drag their body and hide it
yeah just walk up to it
yeah i remember not so long ago
republicans were trying to ban
violent video games because they said it
would spur on
you know school shooters but there
actually have been some studies citing
how violent video games help
people become less violent they vent
yeah so they're able to vent and
you know express themselves and do
really silly silly things like they do
in grand theft auto
and it usually according to some studies
leads to
uh more harm reduction like it's they're
kind of metaphors for like
aiming and throwing a ball at a a moving
target like it doesn't have to be
shooting and killing a human
when you're attacking a character it's
just more like representative of like
building up your
your twitch skill your ability to turn
and fire and there's no actual i
remember uh um
penn tellers be show bs on showtime i
think it was showtime
they did uh uh why the idea that violent
video games makes people more violent
is total bs and they took this kid who
was
i don't remember what video game he was
playing but he was like one of the top
gamers in a certain game
and they gave him an actual pulse fire
you know ar of some sort
and he says little kid i don't know yeah
i could look that up
yeah like like like he fires three
rounds with one
sorry sorry i'm thinking i was playing
destiny and destiny has pulse rifles
they fire three burst fire and the kid
pulled the trigger one time and started
crying
and they were like this kid plays video
games all the time he's one of the best
at this first person shooter
and then they actually you know said all
right let's let's see if you can
they want to see if the kid could
actually hit the target if he was going
to be accurate more accurate like the
video games were training him
and instead he got shocked by like the
recoil and then started crying and then
didn't happen to a mainstream media
journalist i went shooting for the first
time
and then he was shocked and said it was
traumatizing
yes what was he firing something
just a name it's crazy because we look
we we so we we were out in the range and
we had a 556 and a 308
and we were all laughing you know firing
it some little kid shows up with a mini
14
and he he was way better than all of us
he was how old was that kid like 12
i don't remember i wasn't there oh
that's right yeah so i'm like oh man
none of you were there so it's like 12
year old kid shows up with his dad and
his dad's training him and so they're
doing they're very precise
precise and the kid was really really
great we're off in a good time
i fired the 308 a couple times we fired
the 556 and i was i was like wow that's
impressive
then then recently we fired some uh
buckshot and some slugs and the recoil
was
way more so and if this guy
is gonna fire an ar which i can imagine
was probably like a five five six
and then claimed he got ptsd from it
heaven forbid the dude ever hunted a
turkey
because the game load in the 12 gauge
has more recoil
and this guy's like i got ptsd from
firing this way
i feel like we're talking about two
different types of mental
brainwashing one is the actual physical
act
of killing so it's like a violent movie
or a violent video game
the other is the propaganda aspect of
the movie or the video game like the
writing of it
and i i don't i don't think that movies
in video games both have that violent
like action i don't think that
brainwashed people at all
what they're writing about we've no no
that's different what i'm saying is
we've seen studies that show violent
video games don't make people more
violent it's just not true
but you can make people like luke was
saying you play as a small child
crawling away as russians running into
just for no reason
something to like uh what's the what's
the grand theft auto pull just running
up and pulling someone out of a car and
throwing down to like
all this street has anyone ever done
that no there's
amounts of street violence in the united
states in the last five years
no that's actually not true has been
going way down until this past year
still like the last until covered
and then people are angry penned up in
their homes and they go insane
i don't know and police officers police
are being stepping back a little bit
yeah yeah to say that there's
no connection between final video games
and violence i think is extreme they've
done studies what it's like
i've experienced it firsthand when i
play a game i start to think like the
game
when have you ever gotten out of your
car and then just i have self-control
but i've driven and thought like oh
there's a green van and i want to pull
the driver out of the driver's seat
you realize that's goes through a
sounding crazy i'm a normal dude
compared to no
no kids
i had the impulse to do it i've never
had an impulse to do that bro well you
don't play games as much as i do dude i
used to play gta all
the time let me tell you what all the
time means when you're talking about
gaming do you wake up at 8 00 am and
play until 7 a.m yes
five days in a row yes there's no idea
what you're talking about
i used to play video games in his
defense
life i in his defense i play one game
world of warships and i will confess
that playing it has made me want to take
a sailboat out
i got you know what you're right i
played civilization and it made me want
to build a space program to go to mars
yeah the space makes you want to build a
space celebration i got a science
victory and civilization and i was like
what i think let's rally a nation i
think the people that are disturbed are
way more likely to commit violence
anyway whether or not they play the game
i don't care about a couple of studies
what what if
some people are more suggestible than
other people that's for sure
and it's possible that we should take
that what if yeah what if if luke and i
are sitting here
holding those games it could make them
no
training even here's the funny thing
like i just referenced there was a show
from penn
teller where they debunked the whole
thing and luke mentioned studies have
already been done
it's not true and and ian's sitting here
going i don't care because i believe it
is
so you have a few studies you have
literally i have personal experience
i watched them put the doom overlay over
the first person shooter dude
let me see you go crazy from playing
games and other people no i watched the
christchurch shooter with this first
person camera on
laughing like he's playing a game and
people also
taking the video and then making it into
looking like a video game to do with it
you're just you have nothing you have
nothing to back up everything you're
saying as
per usual and you think this justifies
you i would make a point though that you
might actually agree with in the way
that they
do reduce it because you think about
where most crime happens
it's in dense um dense urban areas
around that's where most of crime takes
place because you take those parts the
country away from the united states and
we're like the most peaceful country in
the world you just subtract like
six cities and we're the most peaceful
place in the world so it's happening
there so if you think about
well crime occurs over a period of time
and it's when these
individuals who are who are inclined to
commit crime are inclined to commit it
and they can be doing one of two things
with their time
this kind of goes back to the midnight
basketball theory right i think it's a
little bit more practical
is if you're you've got this video game
it keeps you engaged and you're sitting
around playing it for 12 hours a day
because you're really not capable of
doing anything else
if you're doing that instead of being
out on the street actually doing the
crimes
i think that in some ways it's kind of a
palliative yeah in those specific
environments not to get between your two
argument but i do think that
if you've got something to keep people
wrapped up and engaged they're not
actually out
doing other things which may not include
crimes can i get a drum roll can
you can i get a drum roll drum roll the
guardian
the guardian playing video games doesn't
lead to violent behavior studies shows
the new york times video games aren't
why shooting's happening politicians
still blame them time magazine no
video games don't cause massive reading
now read the article that says the
russians are bad
why it's time to stop blaming video
games for real world via violence
entertainment software association
science says video games don't cause
real world violence
there's five for you ian okay
so it's it's time to stop the witch hunt
and the psychotic
lie i don't dislike video games man i
wouldn't take them away from a kid ever
but i am acknowledging that there's
something to that we become what we do
is five not enough for you oh it's five
i would ask you
who did the study how many people was in
this study i would ask you a question
though
is can you name a single mass shooter
that was moved to do that by video games
that said a video game well i've never
had a chance to talk to any man no but
usually
surely they talk about what the mo the
christ church shooter his motivations
were clearly articulated he wanted
to be a head cam sure i could go pro so
he wanted to cause a civil war by cr by
using gun violence to incite the left to
take guns away from right-wingers in the
united states
right something so i'm just saying that
if it really was causing a problem you
really would have this guy saying well
i play gta a lot look like fun i want to
try out for real i mean maybe they're
they're probably i don't know if they're
consciously i don't know if people are
always conscious
maybe they're not consciously aware well
timmy the big
you know aspect of the violence i you
know i don't think i think
you're right that it's like broken homes
is the worst if we're if i'm gonna pull
up five articles just in a simple google
search in 10 seconds you should probably
stop
saying it article titles i mean read the
articles you should probably stop saying
it if you've not even read anything you
pulled up like a seat cbs is always a pb
guardian pbs yeah new york times new
york times time magazine come on
mainstream i mean okay great read the
articles you're just giving me names and
you've not read anything
dude i've experienced it firsthand maybe
i can find a point of agreement between
the two of you you know would you agree
that the palliative benefit
of violent video games being an outlet
for maybe violent
impulses that they take out in the game
or take up time when they would
ordinarily be out on the street
committing such crimes
outweighs any contributions videos may
have to real-world violence
and i think you would agree with that
too because you yeah of course you agree
so we have some compound officials we
have some common ground here right
okay yeah but i'm not saying it has no
negatives
but i think that's do you both agree
with the premise that i just laid out
definitely okay the way that they help
us
like i it helps me release tension and i
i gain something for the next game
you think the negative is far outweighed
by the positive correct and you think
there's no negative
so okay we have common ground good it's
not that i think there's no negative
it's that over the past several years
now you think there's no doubt
there is negative no no what i'm saying
is it's not about what i believe
okay what you know what i believe i
believe there are numerous scientific
studies that repeatedly
debunk this for the past two decades and
so i'm not gonna
i'm i i personally i'm not telling you
one or the other what i'm saying is
i just read five different headlines
that asserted that citing ref
studies and i started the antidote by
referencing a 20 year old tv show
that debunked the whole thing in the
first place citing numerous scientists
and bringing a kid out okay great you
know you you referenced studies tim
and you've done that before and there
are studies that say fluoride is great
for you
and there's lots of them in fact there's
studies that say aspartame doesn't cause
cancer
and that yes they didn't do any more
studies after that because aspartame
companies didn't want so you're a
conspiracy theorist
no that studies i'm telling you studies
are not the end-all
bro you live you yeah you just told us
that you get impulses but you have
self-control and you want to kill people
tim i don't
i don't i specifically said i don't want
to but i understand i've never
experienced that in my life
brainwashing i've never experienced an
urge to reenact gta in real life tim
tim ian is telling you what happens to
him and that's that's all
and i don't think that ian maybe i don't
think that you should extend that to all
of video
games and all people and that's why tim
is pulling up studies i think
what i'm saying is that if ian is
experiencing some kind of problem he
shouldn't associate that with everyone
well i'm saying or a phenomenon real
well look it's a simple
it's an ontological disagreement he is a
very big believer in deductive reasoning
he's a very big believer in inductive
reasoning and sometimes they have
something in common
sometimes they disagree and that's just
that's what it comes
but how can you read five studies and
then deduce a finality from
five ethnicities because he doesn't see
evidence of it to the contrary if there
was one study that suggested what you
agreed what you suggested he would
actually probably be a little longer
did he look for evidence i just googled
it and clicked the topic
you looked for evidence to support your
claim you didn't what else did you look
for today
well so now it's just a matter of time
he hasn't had time to so i guess
actually that's not true i've had two
decades where i've researched this
extensively and ian has done nothing
no that's the study this stuff i'll tell
you the problem is that i literally have
been reading for decades i do nothing
but read all day
every day i do tons of research
endlessly and then ian says i feel
like i've literally been playing video
games for decades and that's not
research that's you it's
personal research about the way that
video games are anecdote is not data
dude
it is
you're a fireman and you tell me about
how hot fire is i'm going to listen to
you
yeah anecdote is not data let me ask ask
you a question then
if he had spent the last year in a p
working on a phd on this very subject
and
consumed everything and then he said
well i looked at all the evidence i
found little to nothing suggesting that
it contributes to violence would that
affect your point of view
okay okay it's just a disagreement
hundreds of thousands of people that
have gone through it okay and so now
that's not true
so this will stop when you get a phd in
video game violence
so it's an issue of one of the biggest
problems we have
in my opinion with politics in general
is people who think their feelings
are are fact and it's not true period
i don't care about video games i don't
care if they cause violence or don't
cause violence the research says they
don't do you think violent movies cause
people to become more violent i have not
researched it but i believe the answer
is no i believe why
if you would you believe that if you
haven't researched it because what we
have seen is that there
is in some because i've not done the
amount of research i've done into video
games and violence
is like probably to me notable in that
for the past two decades i've actually
been looking up articles and reading the
science on it
fairly often the movie stuff i've read a
couple things and what i've seen is
there is a short-term burst of
aggression after watching violent films
but it's short term and doesn't lead to
real world violence that's what we've
seen so far
so that's the extent that i can get and
i would probably say that suggests
no regular people don't have impulses to
go out and commit crimes because they've
watched a movie
so listen facts don't care about your
feelings if video games caused violence
i'd be sitting here saying that was the
case
but politicians have used it as an
excuse for moral authoritarian power for
censorship for a long time do you think
that watching someone commit a crime
makes you
more more or less likely to commit the
crimes be less likely actually do you
think somebody's not emphasized
the victim like like someone up on a
stage or rating and telling people to
cause violence would make them more
likely to cause violence telling people
to commit a crime yes
in the real world experiencing it with
your eyes and your ears telling someone
that there is a tangible thing affecting
you
and burn it down yes do you think that
people can ever forget they're in real
life and think they're in the video game
while they're playing the game
schizophrenics
yeah yeah yeah yeah me too and we've not
seen
evidence of a widespread or direct
correlation
or direct insidiousness no i think you
think facts are fac uh feelings are
facts
then they're not your personal anecdote
is not data it's it that's
it i think people can forget they're in
the video game and that can really make
them think that they're watching a real
person
the fact that you said you think anak
the plural of anecdote is data
you just don't know anything about
research in general the plural of
anecdotes
you just said that you haven't
researched if movies cause violence but
you believe they don't
in in related news in related gamifying
news i have i have a i have a thing that
maybe could put us on a different track
here
in related gaming news youtube today is
accused of
gamifying the like and dislike button
for all of the videos from the official
white house youtube channel as there are
many screenshots
portraying likes that are supposedly
according to some people being
manipulated in real time have you guys
heard
i blame violent video games for this
youtube has done it to the like button a
lot the issue is though
are the likes legitimate yes we don't
know if there was
actual individuals manipulating the
system because there's usually also some
bots
that are implemented that do create fake
likes and fake dislikes out there so we
don't know if this was the exact
situation that
unfolded here but also surprisingly the
the president that was elected and had
more votes than
any other president in american history
looks like he is getting absolutely
ratioed and dunked on even with
the corrections from youtube as his
videos are having 90 percent
dis like percentages but that's because
people voted against trump
yes no one likes biden right yeah a lot
of people didn't like trump
so people are like why can't why why
won't people show up for joe biden
because nobody wanted him
yes but they just didn't it was it was
it was that's why joe biden hid
because the campaign was i don't like
donald trump or i like donald trump
yeah it it still is like surprising
seeing
the the likes the dislikes even with the
the supposed corrections i hope youtube
addresses the the kind of allegations
because we're seeing some of the videos
being unlisted
uh and then coming back with a whole
different ratio but again we don't know
what's happening
you may take the netflix solution
because you remember when net when left
amy schumer netflix what did they do
they got rid of that system yes right
after amy schumer's
like netflix special debuted and it was
like
promoted everywhere rotten tomatoes i
think he gave it a 98
when actual critics gave it what uh i
think i forgot the exact same
person and then
and then they were like we have the
perfect solution here we're just going
to totally get rid of
all the percentages so you can't even
see the exact ratings
only left up to the professionals and
again we're seeing people's voices just
being slowly taken away we saw this with
comment sections
a couple years ago i was screaming about
it i was sad to see it
but now i think i think with this
happening there they already disabled
comments on the official white house
uh youtube channel i think it's only
going to be a matter of time until they
disable the likes and dislike button
because it is
it is i wonder if that's illegal though
because sorry but you remember
um uh trump was brought to court for
using his presidential
account to block people they said he
couldn't do that
if that's worthy of a lawsuit for their
disabling comments on youtube there was
court proceedings literally saying
donald trump can't block people because
reply guys
jobs was literally replying to donald
trump
so uh i i mean i what was the do you
know the
court rulings on that what happened yeah
they said he had to unblock the people
he had blocked did he did he don't block
it or was it i imagine
most of them wow most of them not all
wow now they're all out of work those
are
just
guys i believe aoc still has much people
blocked as well and there's a couple
other congress people that are getting
sued as well
i'm seeing i'm seeing a bunch of people
tweet being like man donald trump must
be so
bored right now he's golfing and and
also
youtube just recently also expanded his
suspect suspension for another two weeks
on youtube yeah he's gone yeah they're
not bringing him back so
and a couple banks have also cancelled
his accounts
so yes uh impeachment proceedings are
still going to continue in the senate
and uh yeah things are not really
looking
that good for donald trump to say the
least but things are
uh looking really good for some of our
favorite tv hosts
oh yeah the world is always brighter
with authoritarianism
it's bringing some people to tears check
the story out
if i okay but for those that are
listening uh we're gonna start off this
segment with me asking a simple question
and don't look if you haven't yet don't
look who do you think cried
when uh joe biden won which which
anchor on tv cried probably all the
right wingers all right i know this one
but
who is it luke uh miss uh meadow
rachel maddow from the daily mail who is
the big who is media's biggest biden
suck up rachel maddow cries on air
while al roker fist bumps the president
and the new press secretary jenn
sackey gets a very warm welcome rachel
now
said that she'd worked through half a
box of kleenex on air
amazing oh yes weeping on air and making
fun of trump staffers
rachel maddow a well-known trump critic
confessed on her show
that she worked through half a box of
kleenex while watching the day's events
i'm a faucet that can't turn off
i remember the last time she almost
cried on tv was when
the mueller report came back that donald
trump wasn't colluding with russia
and you could see her struggling not to
cry and there's a really funny video
where the ladies
like filming with her phone and she's
laughing and she goes she crying
it went so viral is amazing they say abc
news's byron pitts drew criticism
for calling biden the nation's papa in
chief after listening to his inaugural
address
i love this one tweet this uh this new
york times best-selling author
said we can now rest uh i can no more
3am
waking up with anxiety it's like when
you were a little kid
falling asleep in the back seat knowing
that dad was driving and everything
would be
okay and i'm just like i wouldn't want
to fall asleep in the car with no with
joe biden driving it
i'd want to be holding on and i'd be
wearing my seatbelt but here's where it
gets interesting
it wasn't just rachel maddow who was
crying it's also
andrew sullivan isn't andrew sullivan a
conservative
i'm not even sure never trump where
anybody is now yeah i don't think it
matters
he tweeted just walking the dog and
finding myself in tears
relief patriotism the ceremony the
ceremony restored
something inside oh my god that's kind
of scary
you know what i mean like the cult like
um
uh the cult like a view of the american
and industrial machine
you know the people who look at uh joe
biden and the establishment
and they just want to drop to their
knees and and worship the establishment
and they cry
when the establishment power is returned
who is it that was walking their dog
andrew sullivan it's like all the murder
and all the death and all of the
authoritarianism they don't care just
well they've got a four year at least a
four year vacation ahead of them because
you know they don't have to do any
critical reporting they just have to
repeat what's said af
uh fed to them by the white house press
officer in the dnc
they don't have to do anything anymore
it was so hard
with trump you know like having to do
work yeah do their jobs
yeah and now literally a lot of their
coverage is aesthetics
and the clothing did you see those
sneakers
look at those chucks that kamal harris
is wearing i mean that's literally
i think it was abc news that sat her
down i mean we're talking about one of
the most
important people in our political
discourse right now and you're asking
her about
sneakers i mean are you kidding me there
was another anchor on msnbc
that i tweeted about that compared
biden's administration
to the avengers literally she said they
are superheroes that will quote
save us all i tweeted well he's more
like thanos with the snap of a finger
who's gonna take away half of your
income
and uh it's just absolutely ridiculous
to have this kind of glorification of
of politicians of power which again just
shows you
the utter lack of responsibility and
duty that these supposed journalists
have
for their profession it's not a
profession it's literally just brown
nosers
here's the issue right when a bunch of
middle american
you know people who lost their job start
cheering for trump and making these
silly drawings of trump riding a tank
and like or riding a velociraptor
i don't care all that much because the
regular people the regular people who
believe
in donald trump when the mainstream
corporate media
uses the might of their billions of
dollars to prop up
one political party and destroy the
other
that's disconcerting if if i see a group
of people like you know i've never
really cared all that much about the
queue stuff
because i'm like i don't care who these
these people are they can believe they
think another little forms they can
believe whatever they want i think it's
bad for them i think it led to bad
things
and it's sad but what about the the
other conspiracy on the left the crazy
russia stuff the putin
calling donald trump during the capital
riot and they prop it up
you know it's difficult to actually get
in
to find these communities that are full
of weird conspiracies it's difficult
it's easy to turn on msnbc and then hear
fake
news and propaganda and insanity and
then start believing it
and they want that q is just a much less
effective version of
cnn and the new york times much less
dangerous
so they create these conspiracies
theories they incite riots with
blm mythology that says that cops are
just going around
gunning down innocent black men because
they're black i mean
th they invented this mythol this the
country burned the entire summer because
of their conspiracy theories
uh q just causes some awkward moments of
thanksgiving
right well a lot of people who stormed
the capital were
cute people like the the viking guy
right so some bad stuff comes in it
right he also believed he was an alien
sure
he was no no no he he well yes but in
the body of a human who bra
and he practices life magic and he
explained that he was
his presence there was to ward off the
dark magic people who would see him and
then go whoa we got like a
a big player we better back off well
that cause his live magic was powerful
yeah that's the insurrection we were
facing could you imagine a government by
that guy
it's like it like the national religion
would be the incoherent ramblings on the
dr bronner's soap bottles
he would probably get more likes on
youtube than biden
i bet he's oh definitely i have a
feeling he still thinks that he
preserved a bunch of people's lives he's
like if i wasn't there so many more
people would have died oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah and maybe he did
he looked kind of funny like he brought
a levity to it so look the
the cue stuff it's it's it's
it bums me out these people just want to
believe it you know they want to believe
that i'm telling you right now they
still believe trump has got a secret
plan
they think the new capital is in florida
and trump is working with the military
and i kid you not because i tweeted this
on the 20th like how long until they
start saying that
you know the real plan was to allow
biden to be president so that way they
would confirm the crime and the treason
had been committed
because if he didn't assume the office
then the treason never happened right
they really believe it sorry no god i
was just saying that you know the way
the media decides to focus on that
particular
group or it always makes me wonder
because they can never quite answer the
questions that
so like let's say q supporters was five
percent of the public
uh maybe it's significant but what if
it's really like point five percent is
there any other
measurement because they sort of focus
in on this demographic of crazies and
and make it seem like well that's common
that's mainstream and they do this
constantly with like they find some
extremists or some weirdo
and make it seem like it's
representative of something large when
in fact it's barely even
that entity or it doesn't exist at all
it's with the caliphate uh podcast that
new york times did it was completely
manufactured
so like all this attention that cues get
who how many people actually are quote
unquote queue has there been a survey
done that established them as something
more than one percent of the population
if that
yeah but it was given life because of
the major censorship efforts a lot of
people who
spewed the q stuff said well if we're
not legitimate why is youtube why is
google why
why is facebook and twitter censoring us
and that of course created a situation
where the conversation
didn't take place in front of everyone
it took place in other parts of the
internet that are far away
in seedy places where crazy people go to
discuss different things and
it even came to a point where youtube
started
banning and deleting videos that were
critical of of cue people
so so how how they say in whenever they
get censored
they say over target yes which is means
that oh no like we've we figured it out
that's why they're reacting this way
they're trying to ban us because we were
right yes jack dorsey actually
sort of admitted this because you
remember after trump was banned off of
twitter
um he sort of and then parlor was kicked
off he made his little tweet thread
and it was very slimy and i don't think
authentic but in the beginning he says
that
banning trump and the other platform you
know what happened to them
has in his words he said caused the
conversation to become fractured
and that's exactly what you're
describing because if we're not all in
the same place talking we can't all
correct the
you know and if somebody goes really far
off the reservation we're all still here
we can just pull them back and put our
arms around them but when they're off on
their own there's the communication's
been broke because they've been banned
off the platform
there there was literal people saying
okay let's look at these q
drops let's let's break them down okay
this didn't happen this didn't happen
this isn't a surgeon
there's they say this is going to happen
let's actually look at this let's see if
there's any evidence let's see if
there's any documents backing this
nothing and slowly talking people out of
it those videos were deleted
bro from youtube they they thought that
mueller was working for trump
they said that mueller they needed a way
to get in a special prosecutor with a
deep state realizing it
and that mueller was pretending to
investigate trump for the press but it
was
actually going to be about hillary
clinton and then it never happened
and they claimed to have found the
location of these camps
and they went to these places and then
there was nothing there and it was years
ago that people like cernovich and jack
pasok some of the highest profile trump
supporters were like dude it's not
real people don't want to let it go and
then when i i remember
it's just been for the past several
weeks people saying
monday's the day the states are gonna
start flipping and the arrests are gonna
happen the storm is coming
nothing happens yeah then i remember the
day before inauguration
i had people posting on i see people
posting on facebook tomorrow is the
final day they're waiting for the last
moment then binding is inaugurated
and then all of a sudden there are these
crazy posts popping up like what's
happening what's happening i'm so
confused
and then the next day it's all part of
the plan it's all part of this
was it a real thing with someone that
actually had info but then it just got
co-opted by
crazy people they're like i'm gonna
pretend like i'm cute and tricky
everyone it's like nostradamus
it's like you know someone i'm gonna
make a prediction for you right now
the dark eagle the moon
green blades grass
friday at some point in the next several
years
someone will find this clip and they
will associate those random things i
just said and be like
he was right i didn't say anything or i
could ask questions oh cute does he ask
questions
why is nancy pelosi wanting machine guns
why is the national guard
refusing to answer why they're there
yeah they asked a lot of questions
that's what q does yep
ask questions why is the military moving
a plane in the dead of night to joint
base andrews
why did another plane go to texas and
they call themselves q
because that's the name of that guy from
star trek because of the
queue clearance what's that the highest
level of security clearance you can get
so they say okay
i'm i don't know if that's true i don't
know well a lot of people attribute what
happened with q as a government-run
psychological operation as a psyop
because if you look at the effects of it
it essentially undermined not only
donald trump but any form of legitimate
criticism of government
you know instead of actually considering
what the government has been doing
the american foreign policy where our
tax dollars are going
people were talking about riddles on the
internet and looking for things that
weren't really there at
all from the very beginning and when you
see the cause and effect
a lot of people are saying hey this was
directly done in for nefarious purposes
that
essentially backfired on anyone who
believed in it you know you know what
you know what else is just like that
voter fraud no here's my point is
because
look this type of research i did was
into something that was much more
concrete and practical
whereas these voter fraud conspiracies
just made it seem like the entire
election
was um a result of voter fraud now i've
said what i've said in other channels
about what i think would happen but the
problem is what this has done is
distract us from something that had a
much bigger impact than illegal ballots
which was over the last four years with
hundreds of millions of dollars
the left went on a registration march
they did aggressive voter registration
voter engagement and voter turnout that
was unmatched on the right
that had a much bigger impact than
anything
related to fraudulent ballots voter
fraud etc
however because we're all absorbed with
this voter fraud thing we're not paying
attention to the real problem
which is those uh conservatives
those on the right are just completely
negotiate
did nothing on the voter registration
side to match what the left was doing
but as long as we're talking about voter
fraud we're not paying attention to the
real problem which is exactly what
you've said
and it was a lot of rule changes over
the past year yeah that too it was
it was well before coveted that
pennsylvania passed the law these are
republicans by the way
for mail-in voting so that's that's why
i say the whole thing was actually trump
getting oceans 11.
the real the real the real moves were
made well in advance of the election
and we were watching it happen there was
even controversy where trump was like
you know oh don't vote by
you know oh vote by mail is bad oh wait
wait wait you should vote because they
realized it was actually
disenfranchising his own voters
the democrats had planned this for a
long time stacey abrams has been running
a
massive get out the vote campaign and
fighting legal battles
to maintain voter registration roles and
things like that so
i i agree with you i think it happened a
long time ago and
i think that's what you're working on
now yeah we'll look ahead america our
primary mission is
registering educating and turning out to
vote disaffected patriotic americans i
have a database
of millions of american citizens who are
patriotic who are not registered to vote
and we're going to go into their
communities just like acorn would do in
on the left
or stacey abrams who do in fulton county
engage these people
get them registered to vote educate them
have events do real community organizing
and turn them out to vote on election
day because nobody on the patriotic
side has done that and that's what our
primary mission is and
and the problem with all this is i bring
this up and then people say well what's
the point
um they're just going to steal the
election again and again i i made the
point that
illegal ballots did have an impact but
nowhere near the impact
of the voter registration and then
lowering the bar to make it easier to
vote those two things together
i think yeah mainland voting uh
republicans overwhelmingly voted in
person
and then you had uh democrats who
overwhelmingly voted early
and so a lot of people don't realize i
hear the same thing over and over again
about like the late
night you know boosts for for these
candidates and it's like
yeah those are those were mail-in ballot
dumps yeah and they were from urban
centers which are overwhelmingly so you
take these two factors
that republicans don't vote by mail for
the most part and urban centers are
overwhelmingly forbidden and you get a
95
biden drop it makes perfect sense you
could see it all
coming and so now what the left has been
saying
is that stacy abrams saved the country
because
her get out the vote campaign in georgia
won them the senate
i also think the republican party burnt
themselves to the ground by not
supporting trump
and by not supporting the people but you
know here we are
now it'll be interesting to see what
happens because trump is talking uh well
i should say it's been reported
trump is floating the patriot party but
i'm i wonder what you think about that
matt because you're
you want to get people registered to
vote what if people come out they get
registered and then they go and vote
patriots at a republican
so uh you know as a c3 we register
anybody who asks us for help for it with
it
regardless of any of their background or
their partisanship
we're just about educating people on
patriotic issues such as
h1b visa abuse or
corporate censorship and election
integrity that kind of thing but
putting on my general consultant hat i
think that any third party attempts are
primarily
operations driven by narcissism and
that here's the premise okay the premise
is that you
don't have enough power to take over the
republican party or the democrat party
and then win a general election so
somehow you're miraculously going to
build a party from scratch
and then win a general election here's
and here's a hard truth that even i have
trouble accepting
is if your electoral coalition doesn't
have people in it that make you deeply
uncomfortable
deeply uncomfortable it's probably not
broad enough to win a general election
it's painful and tough medicine and that
it's it's
you know but some folks just can't
accept that and look i
i use the word narcissism about third
parties and i'm going to explain what it
means that we all know the story of
narcissus
right he's he was fell in love with his
own image
reflecting back in the lake and he
couldn't move away from that and he died
and his i believe his problem wasn't
that he found himself to be so beautiful
he saw in himself perfection that wasn't
his problem
his problem was that he could not find
enough beauty in the real world
to leave that and go seek real
nourishment he fell in love with the
ideal
which did not exist rather than falling
in love with the real
that while imperfect still had
nourishment and
the ability to sustain him and to grow
him and when you look at a political
party gop or democrat and you see
imperfection and you only insist on
perfection that
that doesn't exist that gets you nowhere
unless you're willing to work with other
people whom
are flawed whom you disagree with whom
you may strongly disagree with on some
issues so
your refusal to engage with other
republicans because you think they're
sellouts or rhinos or
let's say you're a democrat you refuse
to engage because you think they are
owned by the banks
well that's your own narcissism refusing
to accept the fact that this is the real
world
and if you want to get anything done in
electoral politics you don't have to
love it but you've got to find a way to
work with others and you can't just fall
in love with your own reflection and go
off and
have any impact that matters very good
points made and i think also a lot of
trump supporters are absolutely
disenfranchised
with all the latest moves he's been
making the last few weeks and
you know for for a lot of people that
i'm seeing are really really
disappointed especially with the
pardoning list
uh that essentially is a big debacle
yeah he could have come out he could
have done one thing you know
could have been julian assange instead
we got crooked cronies
the detroit some people deserve it some
mercenaries
i can understand some of it i can but it
was just a big letdown you know
i have many many criticisms of mitt
romney i could criticize him all day
long
but he did very one very smart thing i
agree is that when he was governor of
massachusetts
he didn't pardon a single person and if
get a president who abides by that
because the pardon power
is really kind of weird it's weird
because it doesn't seem to fit in with
the rest of our government where it's
all
law and order there's a process checks
and balances you know you get convicted
you can appeal et cetera this is like a
magic
wand that exists outside of everything
um and i i think you know to his
in that that's the only thing i actually
think i could say that's good about mitt
romney is that
you know if we had a president who
embraced that he probably avoided a lot
of trouble
because then if he came out the
beginning said i'm not going to pardon
anybody it doesn't exist
then all the lobbying and corruption
that surrounds trying to get those
pardons would immediately evaporate or
what if you said i'm a pardon everybody
yo you don't need a lobby i guess so all
right
everyone that crazy guy who was selling
drugs pardon joe exotic get him out
joe's adam get him a limo could the
president do that technically
yes yes every single one what at least
from federal crimes
yeah federal charges why why can't we
get a president who just does something
just like just do like so i'm not saying
pardon murderers
or like you know diddlers or really
really awful people i'm saying trump
could have sat back with a big old stack
of paper and be like let's see
distribu distribution of marijuana
you're free to go dude if we were in
non-violent offenses that's right that's
an idea we were to get a president that
defied the military-industrial complex
how would that work they would have to
flee the country and like work abroad
i think it would be a problem though if
a president did that because what would
happen
is that the responsibility that
legislators have
and the process of passing legislation
house senate then
prison sign it it would basically
neutralize that and then we would become
this
entity that's completely subject to
a presence women you know they can do
that with executive orders
he can instruct the fbi for instance not
to arrest people for drug charges
there's limits
oh yeah that's different than pardoning
somebody who's been convicted and
there's some limits to what a president
can excuse
you know and we did this before it was a
mistake this is a little bit arcane but
the congress passed a um what i would
consider anti-free speech campaign
finance reform bill
many of them knowing that things in it
were unconstitutional unconscious
restrictions
and what they were going to do is just
count on the supreme court oh the
supreme court will fix it
well it turned out the supreme court
didn't fix it and they didn't actually
get around to even
changing some things about it for
another 10 or 20 years so what i think
would happen is
this the legislature would abrogate the
responsibility to uphold the
constitution because they just assumed
the president would do it or supreme
court somebody else would do it so i
think that would be a downside to
your very wonderful fantasy i just want
to see somebody for once
you know look there are a lot of people
in jail that we know shouldn't be there
because we have too many
rigid uh judges and and lawyers
i'll tell you uh when i was i think i
was how old was i 20 maybe
i got pulled over i had just gone to
colorado to visit my sister on fort
carson
because her husband was in iraq on the
ground as a field medic and she was
terrified and distraught and
i came to to you know just hang out with
her and provide with some company
when i came back to illinois i got
pulled over uh by a cop
and i had no idea why i had done nothing
illegal i wasn't speeding and the first
thing the cop does is he walks up to the
window and he goes you tim pool
yes sir and he goes out of the vehicle
you're under arrest and i was like uh
what's happening and goes you're driving
on a suspended license i am
i had no idea because if you're under
the age of 21 and you get two moving
violations
two different tickets they suspend your
license for three months
i didn't even know that it happened and
i didn't realize that
i had previously gotten a bogus ticket
for speeding when i wasn't i was exiting
off of lake shore
i was onto belmont avenue from lakeshore
drive i was going about five miles under
the limit
and a cop pulled me over and gave me a
ticket so here i am by myself
now my license suspended i had no idea
never received notification had my
license and everything
and the guy says don't worry i'm going
to i bond you if someone can come pick
you up
and i was like okay i guess when i went
to court
the prosecutor asked me you know what
he's like what are you gonna do
if you plead guilty i'll give you you
know we'll do the setting this and i
said can i just let you know what was
going on and like what happened
he said sure and i explained everything
and i was like look i was i was coming
back from visiting my sister
i had not received any notifications
about a suspension and i'm really sorry
it happened and he goes oh thanks for
your confession
uh so it's a year in jail or you're
gonna plead guilty and we're gonna give
you court supervision and you're gonna
pay a fine
and i was like okay and then when i said
when i went to the judge
the judge asked me if i had been coerced
and i said yes and he said what and i
was like yeah he told me i'll go to jail
for a year
unless i just tell him i'm guilty and
the judge rolled his eyes and said get a
lawyer and come back
does that make sense that someone who's
20 who got
one who got who out i got a tail light
out and a speeding ticket now they want
to throw me in jail for a year or
threaten me with that i think that makes
literally no sense
and it's ridiculous that our system has
become so rigid that they would say
i don't give a damn about your family i
don't give a damn that your
brother-in-law is serving in iraq and
you want to do the right thing
you broke the law whether you knew you
did or not oh you were just driving not
breaking any laws in fact
my one lawyer told me he had no right to
pull me over in the first place it was a
violation of this
was it called the uh probable cause no
that is the exclusionary uh rule
that he i had to have committed a crime
to get pulled over in the first place
but i had no way to fight that i had no
way to get a lawyer
to say why did you pull over my client
uh well because i ran his plate and saw
his name what if it was someone else
driving the car
that was not a legal stop therefore it's
out no i couldn't afford that i had no
way to fight it
and so here i am some 20 year old dude
who who had never got a notification
no one says to you when you're when
you're 16 or 18 getting a license by the
way if you get
two moving violations will suspend your
license they don't mail you notification
at all just one day you get pulled over
it's happened to so many different
friends of mine
and they actually threaten you with jail
time for something that
for what for what there's no there
there's no
human can there's no human emotion in
the system right now
and so how many people are rotting in
prison for something as nonsensical as
that
especially when it comes to someone who
wanted to smoke
smoke a little weed in their own privacy
their own home hurting nobody
and so i'd love to see this system for
once look at all the people who have
been arrested for for advocating for
jury nullification you guys know about
this luke you know about oh yeah 100
that the juries have the ability to
nullify if they think someone shouldn't
be punished for it but if you advocate
for that they'll arrest you
really the system is broken is it
illegal to advocate no
but they do it anyway and they charge
they they give people on contempt of
court
well the question is though what are you
going to do about it i mean you're
talking about
what are you going to do about it that's
why i like the idea to finally get a
politician who's going to look through
all of these different cases and i'd
love to see a president say the first
thing i'm going to do is
oh we're going to do executive orders
but i want to see i want to see
advocacy and review as many pos cases as
possible to figure out if we can be
human beings again
to see if people actually deserve to get
mandatory minimums
there's a story i learned when i was at
college of dupage about a kid
who was whose family was watching their
neighbor's home and he went inside and
he took a beer
and he got four years in prison on a
mandatory minimum for robbery
and the j and the judge refused the uh
the judge
said it's a mandatory minimum you went
in the house and you took property
and when they said yeah but we were
asked to watch the house
it doesn't matter you went in and took
someone's property
it wasn't yours and the people who live
and said we we don't care about the beer
we invite them doesn't matter the prison
rejected the kid
this is a story that i don't you can
look at this up as illinois is a story
that i was told
and this is now 16 years ago the prison
when they when they reviewed the notes
on what the story was and why he was
getting four years
they wouldn't let him in the prison and
the judge intervened and the kid went to
prison
what the what is wrong with this system
i i haven't
got another example that i think is
really worth noting here or if you're in
california and your child misses school
and then you have camilla harris as the
uh you know prosecutor there who's going
to punish the parents and literally have
criminal
charges brought on them because of that
yeah there's actually a harvard
law professor that came out and said on
average
an american a day commits three felonies
on average because of how many laws we
have on the books and that's to me
way too many laws and that's and that's
a good point too but you know
on top of that i'm just trying to point
out that there's
there's no humanity in the system at all
it's the
like illinois has mandatory minimums for
drug charges
it's like dude come on are we really
gonna take someone who's got an
addiction
and lock him in a prison for four years
it's not solving the problem it's making
it worse
and they don't care look at what
happened in michigan
when these juvenile detention centers
the judges were selling kids to them
the system is broken in so many ways and
i wanted trump to just take a hammer and
just whack it just a little bit not
break it
just give a big middle finger to the
messed up nature of how the system works
but i would i would i don't mean this is
criticism but i think there's a fatal
flaw
because when i asked you what you're
going to do about it you said yo i just
hope wish there was this politician or
this president i wish president trump
it's got to be you tim it's got to be
you and
these methods that i brought up this is
hard work
it's hard work and i hear your
complaints i understand it but we have
to remember something is that
the country that we have where we do
generally generally like the country
despite yours this country was founded
because a man
rounded up a bunch of other guys on
christmas on
in the middle of the night and crossed a
freezing river and fired guns at other
people
because our great grandfathers drowned
in mud in trenches
because our grandfathers died on a beach
so we
for us to expect that things are going
to go well for us without making similar
efforts or even efforts even 10 percent
of that i think is is unreasonable so
all these problems you're talking about
mandatory minimums in illinois i know
there are groups that are out there
active
actively lobbying to reform them and
it's not going to happen overnight but
it's one step at a time this issue with
uh young people getting two moving
violations having their lives
what happened to you there's just there
are multiple solutions available to us
get that prosecuted those guys are
elected you can get rid of them
or change the law itself so all these
things are fixable but it takes time it
takes effort it takes training and
organization and
i and so we are we are doing stuff we
got to do stuff we're
we're talking about it on on our show
and bringing you on because
you are the guy boots on the ground
working towards those solutions
i have always been uh you know i used to
do fundraising for nonprofits
that helps my it was always uh it was
always marketing and events and
awareness
and i'm still doing essentially the same
thing building awareness and spreading
information into certain capacity so
if i can highlight the issue and then i
can showcase what you're working on
because it'll help solve those problems
then we're doing that we're we're doing
the right thing absolutely and
that's my abilities those c3s i'll tell
you if you do fundraisers for them
that's that's mana from heaven because i
can tell you from somebody running one
it's you'd like to think it didn't
matter but money matters
a lot for everything from like mandatory
minimums to election reform
to getting we need professional staff to
train and organize these
grassroots lobbyists to get out in the
field and everything is expensive
everything costs money so i
my hat's off to a few if you actually
step forward and do fundraisers for
organizations like that
that that is some that is tremendous and
it makes a difference
people donate to your 501c3
lookaheadamerica.org
what do you use the money for um well we
would be raising we have staff that we
would send out
into the state of virginia this year
because there's an election to literally
go door-to-door registering americans
where we know they live and they're not
registered to literally stand outside
of costco for 18 hours a day and outside
of walmart registering people
with and going to high school football
games going to evangelical
hispanic churches and remember when we
register somebody that's not the
beginning that's not the end of our
relationship with them that's the
beginning
so we're going to continue communicating
them letting them know how important it
is that they vote what issues matter
where politicians stand on these issues
like
mandatory minimums for example and then
when the election comes
turning them out to vote making sure
they're educated on where the candidates
stand on those issues now we don't tell
them who to vote for we're not partisan
but that's literally what the money goes
to is having people go out and train
volunteers
and ra and going to these state capitals
like we could go to the state capitol of
illinois and organize people to go talk
to
their representatives because you know
these these representatives believe it
or not they're not that's they're not
geniuses right and many of them have
like 20 issues in front of them and the
reason those issues are what's in front
of them is because that's what got
pushed in front of them
so if their constituents start pushing
these uh mandatory minimums say hey we
got to get rid of these
suddenly they'll do they'll do something
about but they don't do it unless you
get you know not physically or violently
but you got to get in their faces
and make sure this is an issue that will
determine whether or not they get
reelected and then they start to listen
and figuratively get in their face like
literally approach them and say hey i
want this changed
uh politely always polite but um
passionate well informed and um always
you know ready to engage them on in this
is how the democracy works is
once because if we're not going to do it
this way then i mean you just imagine
what you saw on january 6 times a
thousand plus
automatic weapons because that it's
either this way or some other
alternative this this is all we've got
the famous quote is those who make
peaceful revolution impossible make
violent revolution inevitable
i've heard that yeah was that jfk said
that who's that it's a genius quote i'm
going to look it up
it sounds like more like a one of those
um
shakeover type maybe but you don't take
it too it's
the literal idea of like overthrowing
your government it's just generally if
we can't
change the government and solve these
problems then people eventually explode
right but i don't think you get to go
explode if you haven't
tried talking to yours if you don't know
the name of your state legislators
and you're complaining about things then
i you're
get out of here it was candidates come
on man kennedy those who make peaceful
revolution impossible make violent
revolution inevitable
yeah remarks on the first anniversary of
the alliance for progress 13th of march
1962.
well there it is how about we jump over
to them super chats
if you haven't already smash the like
button hit the notification bell
subscribe and
share the show if you really do like it
that's the best way to help but also go
to timcast.com
become a member because our first super
chat says what are you guys going to
talk about twitter refusing to take down
bad stuff bad videos of children yes
we're going to do a bonus segment
because we're going to get into
like this is a serious story there's a
lawsuit going on between twitter and
some very very serious issues so this is
going to appear
on timeguest.com i'll talk about that
the one benefit
so look i don't like putting things
behind pay walls when it's very very
important news
there's also uh concerns of
youtube silencing and shutting down and
protecting their allies in silicon
valley so
one of the reasons we set up
teamcast.com was to protect ourselves
from the threats of censorship and we
are going to go
and rail and go through this you know
story and stuff so stick around become a
member of timcast.com and
uh we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna
really rail against these big these big
tech companies
gearyvision says you're right tim the
first m16s issued in nam were automatic
but were quickly retrofitted to
semi-auto because soldiers would
disregard training by using spray and
prey
instead of aiming and firing which is
more effective that's why it's the m16a2
that they have interesting one was fully
automatic the a2 went to
burst it wasn't selective like they
could but they got rid of the select
full auto because
yeah the a1 had full auto then they got
rid of it so it was basically
single burst and safety and those of us
have civilian versions have safety and
single yep yep interesting
gareth green says dvd didn't exist when
return of jafar came out it was the age
of vhs
thanks for letting us know alexander
ferris says i totally agree with you
guys indeed i hate censorship
free speech is good screw censorship i
hate it political correctness is so
stupid
yes sean anderson says but didn't joe
biden say antifa is an idea not an
organization
during the presidential debates how can
this poor man fight phantoms
that is a good question all right let's
see
eric says have you seen the video of
biden saying salute the marines while
walking past marines without saluting
them
yeah maybe he was just telling his wife
to do it i saw that video and people are
claiming that
he was instructed to do it like someone
in his ear piece told him and then he
just repeated them instead of doing it
or his wife was in front of him and he
said salute the marines
i hope that we don't why would his wife
salute the marines going in there and
people say that they did see an earpiece
in there but
it's just kind of weird not do it though
because
she said why would they tell him he's in
the military she's not he's the
commander she's not in the military
so he they were telling him to salute
them and he just repeated it
well that's the theory but who knows i
hope that we don't go down a path of
hating on biden
i kind of want to avoid make pointing
blame game anymore
because that happened for four years and
it was really annoying i hear you i hear
you biden is literally the devil he's
the most evil man
ever on the planet he's uh i'm kidding
no i think biden is i think he's crooked
i don't like the guy
but uh uh you know what if he does good
things i'll say he did good things
you know if he comes out and he uh i
know i can't
personally well he's already bolstering
our troops in the middle east right
well he's considering uh reversing
trump's uh
orders sending troops home so uh i mean
when you look at his foreign policy it's
very hawkish
donald hutchins says tim first super
chat joining the website today thank you
for speaking truth here
uh here is to your building a truth
empire
well to the best of our abilities not
everything i say is correct and not
everything we say is correct
we just uh we'll try to be honest the
best of our abilities and uh for those
of you that have joined if you're having
an issue you can email members at
timcast.com and we'll get you sorted
it's a new site so there's some bugs
we're getting them we're getting fixed
there's a third-party plug-in or
something because
certain uh email providers aren't
working properly but we'll get it fixed
we'll get it fixed just you know members
at tempgates.com
nuclear wintergamer says i bought a 3d
printer this this new year
and we'll try and make things for myself
and not give money to ccp
there's no reason why we can't make
things seriously could you imagine
if uh you just bought a 3d printer and
started manufacturing basic goods
like you bought a bunch of abs and like
what do people need what can you make
out of plastic and get printed and then
sell it on the shelf custom built parts
that you can't easily get unless you're
unless they're shipped from china you
could just now 3d print them if you have
the right skills to do so
and if you have a 3d printer you can
tell your friends you know just
a little bit of profit on top and i'll
print it up for you and they'll be ready
in a couple hours
it's a lot of work i mean we have a 3d
printer here i'm still trying to get the
basic
kind of understanding of it but
it's fun it's really cool stuff
patrick mulligan says the jacobin biden
jesus cover was an obvious joke
you know we realized that at the end
like maybe it was supposed to be
tongue-in-cheek i guess the issue is
there were too many posts from actual
leftists
i referenced it where they talked about
the sun breaking like the clouds
breaking the sunlight
beaming down on biden and so i was like
why would i assume that was a joke when
they've been tweeting all of this stuff
non-stop
to be fair jacob is leftist not
establishment necessarily
and so they've been critical of
democrats so we probably should have
caught that one
and that's on us by all means feel free
to rag on us i'm sure the leftists are
scott hale says tim big question why
won't a social media platform pay a
percentage of data
into info revenue and ad revenue to all
its participants
i feel like this helps both parties lift
up the bottom of society
five percent would be it would be big
for most
maybe but uh twitter's got what 300
million users
their profits aren't nearly that high
you'd get a penny i i've heard people
say the whole like buy your
own your data stuff and i'm like they
make point zero
like they make they make point one of a
cent you know mines is doing it if you
sign up for mines plus so it's like i
don't know what just 10 bucks a month or
something then you get a they split 25
percent of the revenue with
the user base the minds plus user base
interesting
but there's no revenue isn't just from
mines pro it's like there's other
sources of revenue and then
i mean it feels like you should it's
some way for you to make money off the
fact that you're allowing yourself to
see advertising
i mean it feels like i should be paid to
look at advertising like in a monetary
form yeah through those
networks if if you have 100 people
paying 10 bucks
all right yeah it's more than that it's
it's based on your
the the negativity that you drive
through my space if you have 100 people
who are in the pro program paying 10
bucks
that means mines makes a thousand
dollars and then pays out 250 back to
the users
it's kind of pointless i think that's
the yeah but if you're the one
that does a lot of activity you might
put ten dollars in but get forty dollars
back
so it's not about percentage it's about
activity-based
yeah they're payback of the of their
revenue they pay back 25
of it divided equally amongst the people
like sub stack
is that what it does i mean they you
draw
people eyeballs to content either on a
social network or on
a website and they're kind of just the
managers of the
ads placements and revenue collection
they just hey
i think brave also shares ads that you
see yeah on their platform so
all right let's see texas horse rescue
says count me and matt texas spends a
fortune on state contracts with these
tech giants
hit him in the wallet stop hate create
good ideas change the world
texas is at the top i was just there in
austin and that's at the top of our list
for this initiative
and i look i look forward to seeing you
at our online training session a week
from now
yeah jason m says give us a website
please i want to work with your guest
tell us how
lookaheadamerica.org
uh garhant says put out a digital
magazine for d d adventure adventurers
and content as part of timcast.com
donation
imagine having orcs being savage and
drow actually
being blue which of the coast has
removed uh
is removed that find writers ian you
want to make d and d
books create like a a mythology of our
own call it something different but use
dwarves and dark dwarves and drow and
drink hold on hold on we were talking
about doing a culture war
d d kind of thing that was like way over
the top like
yeah you know i mean the the rule sets
open source
so do they just want like a magazine
like a story
art or a digital magazine for d d
adventurers
so badass i wasn't cool enough to play
dungeons and dragons as a kid you're
always cool enough yes let's see uh it's
just me says man i tried to donate to
lookaheadamerica.com and it wouldn't
allow me to donate is it lookamerica.org
look look ahead america look ahead of me
look ahead of america.org
i think this is amazing and i've been
encouraging friends to get involved
hope to be on the wednesday training
sounds good cool
let's see where we're at now uncultured
barbarian says
uh check out operation trust sometime
because it's basically queue but in the
1920s soviet union
they used well-known generals to
convince the monarchist that they had a
secret plan in the works to bring back
the czar
and the bolsheviks sound well
interesting
i mean that's one way to do it right
let's see
no dice says i'm a 20 year old 20 year
old from enemy lines here on long island
and i can say that we gen z is a bit
more right wing
that some give credit for it seems to me
that patriotism is a form of
counterculture
it is it's true yeah mr hunt
first name mike says a nation in
distress
we are turning our flags upside down
many people are i've seen that
yeah alexander farah says bloodborne is
violent but i don't think it makes
people violent
violent video games is a good it is a
good think it's free expression
i love this debate we should i would
love to go like way way deep on this
because i think it's like so pervasive
in society video games
undoubtedly are pervasive in society and
i just i love it brady says so when does
the division go from game to documentary
a lot of people pointed out that dc
looks like the division two
have you guys ever played the division
two no but i remember hearing that it
had references to dark winter
yeah the official war game that happened
uh that you know joe biden biden said is
going to happen yes
amazing choice of words joe so operation
dark winter was a war game about a
pandemic
uh the the division the first game that
came out
you're in new york it's quarantined the
virus has been released
and directive 51 has been enacted
because this the country is in danger
and
directive 51 gives the ability to create
a new continuity of government
essentially override the existing
government
and then you are the division agents
going in to stop these rogue groups
so then the division two takes place in
dc and there's
barricades and fences everywhere and
road groups around dc it's a really good
game i i played both pretty extensively
yeah good fun the the the new york
design was amazing they
i remember like living in new york and
playing it and explaining to people that
i knew where everything was because i
lived here and i knew where it was it's
like oh we got to go to radio city
musical i know where that is just follow
me
like everyone else is like well look on
the map you don't need to i live here
it's just down the corner and we tunnel
it wasn't it wasn't to scale or anything
like that
fran pham says ian there are native
americans in in
our red red dead redemption in fact the
later half of the game is centered on
them
red dead redemption 2 mostly doesn't
have the natives violently attack you
and vice versa because that's
well you know what not pc i know
for better or worse
let's see where we're at
senjito says impulse to cause harm ian
needs some therapy or something man
that might be true joshua brunson says
ian and tim's discussions are the best
you see
that's entirely the point you belong
here josh
uh goatman jack says i love when tim and
ian get heated lmao
especially when it's about video games i
feel bad about trying to broker peace
because maybe i just sort of thrown some
kindling on the fire
you should have joined my side and you
should have joined the inside okay yeah
totally down
but but not like argue with us goading
us on
yeah luke's just like you're so right
tim don't let him don't take this from
them
i'm gonna do that next time what did
someone say uh httr says ian please
don't carjack anyone
i won't i promise uh
george uracich says in 2077 what makes
someone a criminal
gaming that's the joke from the uh the
commercial
isn't it like illegal to game in china
they banned online gaming
uh well some people are so compulsively
obsessed with it that they started
to uh like ban people from uh
gaming too much because it's it creates
too much social harm but there was
something about they didn't want them
interacting with the outside world so
they like
ceased their ability to play multiplayer
games with like americans
i don't remember that delamar says ian
is stepping on it youth crime stats have
gone
down all crime as the rise of video game
play over 20 years stop equating
internet trolls and sick jokes with fps
sporkwich says books were blamed for
deviants
then comics then rock music now video
games it's the same progression of
scapegoats as always
no evidence that it's causative some
correlation with violent people being
drawn to them
that's a good point oh yeah maybe maybe
you're just a violent person ian oh you
know me so well
yeah but no one really wants to talk
about the root cause of violence that's
the thing
it's always scapegoated so you guys made
a very very good one well
it is it's demons obviously they enter
your soul at night
it's probably time you wake up like
social economic conditions fatherless
homes
there's things to really argue here
there's things that we should really
have a conversation about but
that's never going to happen because
it's all something else i feel like
trump was a good example of people that
didn't have like strong relations with
their father
would would look for like a strong male
figure and he
just offered something so the first time
that
they'd seen that and that's why he has a
lot of like young
men i think had a lot of like young
madnesses
jordan peterson was giving purpose and
responsibility to young men
and that's why they were they were drawn
to him he said find the heaviest thing
you can carry and carry it
where so i think one of the big factors
in today's day and age is
the millennial generation and much of
gen z you have
the leftists who have found purpose in
social justice
and then you had a bunch of not super
politically active people with no
purpose
and then they found someone like jordan
peterson the left realizing that their
opportunity to radicalize and
indoctrinate was being stopped
by someone like peterson called him a
nazi and all right and all that stuff
when he was literally just like
a self-help psychologist being like you
should work on yourself and be
responsible and they're like
no don't teach them to be responsible
and have purpose in their lives
we need to tell them the only path to
purpose is through us
so he was a threat he studied like the
gulag archipelago and the rise of
totalitarianism he's like i've studied
the nazis i know where they come from
and they're like he's a nazi
what is going on we have we have a very
important super chat casado says
everyone is always focused on the idea
that video games make people violent
but i'm over here in the corner trying
to choose the dialogue option that
doesn't upset the npc
yeah i always play the good guy yeah the
first playthrough no
you know but yes there's a funny meme
where
it was like now that i've beaten the
game through as a good
guy in my first playthrough i'm going to
play as evil and then it shows like
a camera which game it was but there was
someone asked like do you like my work
of art it's taken me a long time and
i've worked very hard on it you can
choose it's the worst thing i've ever
seen or like it's terrible
and then it showed a picture of uh like
a guy gaming crying like pressing the
button
like he couldn't he couldn't insult the
npc it hurt his feelings
that's funny let's see
we'll move down a little bit daniel
bundrick says the children of the
revolution always eat their parents
we got a lot of super chats we got too
many because we got heated
you can tell the chronological order
because it's mirroring how our
conversation we got
then we got to video game discussion and
uh it's funny when you watch the live
chat
along with videos some people are like
behind and they'll be like so you'll see
the chat they'll be like ah ian's an
idiot
and they'll be like oh i can't wait to
see what ian said it makes him an idiot
daniel maxwell says what ian is saying
was also said about dungeons and dragons
before video games became common in both
cases
the only people who actually do engage
in violence as a result
were those who did not have a firm grip
on reality from grasp on reality
yeah i remember the the dnd scare yeah
in the 80s yeah they were claiming it
was like demonic and
magic the gathering had to change their
art because religious groups were
offended by it
let's see we got here akapot says be
fair be fair to ian tim don't harm your
team dynamic for arguing micro versus
macro
ian wasn't arguing on the macro level
listen to his insights better bro
we can all do this better it's what we
need most right now
there you go
says the military according to
ex-trainers use realistic video training
similar simulators
in part to desensitize soldiers to
killing
immersion in realistic killing may not
cause violence but it makes it easier
interesting
lizard says hi tim i'm a 19 year old
libertarian girl very grateful for your
show
my co-workers talk about about causing
harm to trump supporters at rallies like
it's nothing
crazy times i'd love to see you have
kyle kalinski and or jordan peterson on
i would love to have either of those
individuals on the challenge with
someone like kyle's
we can't tell someone hey don't do your
show come to our show they're gonna be
like but i have to do my show and it's
like yeah i get it i was thinking we
should get jordan and his wife when we
get them
well michaela might come too yeah yeah
well maybe we could do a weekend special
with kyle
does he do shows on the weekend i don't
know i wouldn't mind working extra
on a saturday or sunday i'm down i would
like to take kyle to arrange
yeah let's do that that'd be fun he's a
cool dude he really is
kyle and crystal ball are really awesome
uh they they there's
there's there are a lot of people on the
left and a lot of people on the right
who are both grifters
um i like to give credit where credit is
due and i think crystal ball and kyle
are red crystal was great until she
banned me from her show
in the middle of the show in the middle
of the show she text her producer and he
came over and said you're out of here
what happened
well i made a joke and i didn't mean it
as an insult
i didn't mean as an insult per se
because in many circles this is a
compliment
and was the reason that you know the the
type of person people said we should
nominate for president the republican
party
i made a joke about um beto
o'rourke being a beta male i just made
you know beta
beta that's that's what i said and so
she kicked you off in the middle of the
show
kicked me off and i used to i was
invited
crystal ball crystal what crystal on
cigar or
what yeah really yeah i was on the show
a few times the producer loved me
it's easy trip i went in and then they
all came on me like
after i made that comment i i was like
well i tell you wise because he ran away
from the police
and didn't accept responsibility for it
cursing everywhere like immature child
and running around the skateboard
because i think beta male is basically
an immature guy
right this might take on it although
beta male was supposed to be like the
savior right
plus he was good at skateboarding oh i'm
sure he was great at it because i need
time
i've seen your i've seen your uh
whatever it is you guys write on the
ramp i've seen the ramp
no but i said that and then the other
guest jumped up me for like promoting
toxic masculinity
and she got it's basically like i used
an ethnic slur
is was her reaction and we went to
commercial break
texted her producer very upset producer
came over and said hey
you're out of here and they never
brought me back so i've been banned for
the show for that
they wouldn't just let you be like hey
don't do that again well no i'm like i
would tell you this is why i use those
words
and uh you disagree okay that's cool but
nope it was like that's a bummer
yeah yeah i like the alpha beta gamma
talk with like gamma well i i think of
myself as an omega i was like what is an
omega because
no i'm the omega man you're not an omega
omegas are like
they don't really they kind of given up
on being omegas are are black
no omegas are black-pilled individuals
who are
short and have physical i was getting i
was getting all sorts of different
descriptions of what the omega was an
alpha male
is a confident leader yeah betas are
those that surround themselves
that surround the alpha so people think
beta means weak it doesn't
the beta is lieutenant it's like a
subservient personality
and inoffensive and non-threatening
which is why for a while
that's not true well that at least in
political speak that's what the world of
political male consistency was meant
it's like the opposite of a trump
an alpha male would be trump and then
dance covenant would be a beta that's
not an insult
it means that he's the he's the second
in command or he's one of trump's
lieutenants
that definitions i get i get it
omega males are the hunchbacked like
you know don't look at me i don't hear
and they they can't socially interact
starting to identify with that okay go
on yeah
so people think beta means weak and you
know ineffectual or whatever
the the beta is the guy who's standing
behind there's like a tall guy in a bar
going like
you're so dumb i'm tough and then his
friend goes he yeah you tell him boston
omega's the outcasts right that's me i
think the betas are high fiving the
alphas the alpha goads
i've been so jaded by the situation that
i'm just here to play
but beta you're right in colloquial
speak it's come to represent
you know like weak well not necessarily
weak but just
non-threatening and for a while i was
sitting at a a political conference and
this consultant to mike pence sat next
to me
and was talking about the fact that you
know in 2016 we really need to
nominate a beta male because that's who
the women really want and that's sort of
the context i used with on
crystal balls well to go back to that
because and apparently that
that caused a big controversy and it's
like the top six of my google search
results are
you know the the controversy and i got
death threats from that
so you know and i'm not i am not
generally complain about it i
anybody i always sort of wince when i
see somebody in the public complaining
about death threats first of all
somebody's going to kill you're not
going to threaten you first
secondly um everybody who sticks their
neck out even a little bit gets
all kinds of crazy stuff but it just it
solicits so much of a reaction that it
got you know i was searching
like all this stuff a couple nights ago
and um was noticing all
how it was like giving me the
descriptions of the identity politics
definitions of it all like beta
beta on beta is like two guy or a woman
and a two women
in a beta woman and it was giving me all
the like the
transsexual people type descriptions
about it all i had no idea that
was involved in the you know lgbtq
community yeah i mean neither in fact
you know the funniest thing about
them kicking me off for calling him a
beta male and you know making fun of his
name the alliteration
is that all of their supporters got on
twitter and said
no you're the beta male it's like oh
okay all right i guess it's
whatever yeah yeah sure whatever that's
a bummer though uh
you know i guess nobody's perfect but uh
i've i've been on with crystal and cigar
sounds like we gotta have you and
crystal
i was there before cigar was buck who is
a great guy oh that's right that was a
while ago buck sexton
yeah yeah yeah yeah well it would be fun
to have uh
it it would be fun to have you know one
of these like lefty personalities come
and
you know i would love to learn about
firearms don't call anyone a better mail
okay
you know what you know what's a real
bummer is that we're always more than
willing to have any lefty personality
list on the show
but it's it's it's i think two too many
people are just
grifters you know what i mean that their
whole game
is just riling up the people behind them
they got their base behind them cheering
and clapping and they're going to say
whatever they got to say to get that
attention
so you know we've had on a few
personalities that were like libertarian
left libertarian a little bit
and we've gotten thumbs down and people
and the comments like yelling at us and
stuff and i'm like i don't care dude
like i'm not we're not making an echo
chamber for you we're trying to get
multiple voices on the show
we'll argue ian and i just argued we
argue you know what i mean it's like
we're not gonna just say what you want
to hear if you want that there's a bunch
of other places you can go get it so
speaking of that sees of fae says tim
please put
shoe on head put your shoe on your head
oh put shoe on head
oh i thought he was saying have shoe and
head on the show oh uh i don't have any
shoes up here
i'm actually barefoot right now me too
well you can you can no no he
luke's dog's name is fumble bump by the
way oh atlas no because what happened
was we were in the basement
and luke had treats and was trying to
call her over but you were calling her
freedom
yeah and then i just made up a gibberish
word while shaking swedish gummies
and yelled fumble bump and then she like
looked left and right i kept yelling and
luke's like freedom and then she ran to
me so i'm like
done nobody keeps calling her fumble bum
all the time
no it's just going to be a command that
only i can use with your dog
and then when i'm like breaking into
your trailer at night she's growling
i'll go fumble
and then she'll go happy and like oh i
know what that means that means my
friend why are you breaking into my
trailer
he did this once by the way with alex
jones yes yeah luke was sleeping
and alex pulled up and i was like i had
the camera and i was like let's go to
that yeah me and alex have a turbulent
history so it was weird
taking it out that's why i was i i
either meditated
before the show i was taking a nap and i
wake up with alex jones professing his
love for me telling me that he's
that we were in a relationship before
i'm like dude we were about to fight
last time we talked about how many years
ago
now you're here in my room what what is
like
is this i'm gonna put that footage up i
have the footage yeah i just gotta get
it from my gopro
and then we'll and then you'll exploit
me to the fullest degree of course
but at least i get to sell my t-shirts
at thebestpoliticalshirts.com
ew says tim new timcast premium member
here
evan w when you have a chance contact me
i'd like to intro you to a data center
to put your vids on for better
throughput
got good ideas for you we're actually
upgrading everything so
we we might be solving a lot of these
problems but feel free to
to email members at timcast.com dude
uh ben set up the system where i've got
dual wires coming into my room one can
be a server
yeah a whole server we can't handle a
server though i don't know
it would be great if we had our own
servers but you need a ridiculous amount
of bandwidth for that that we do not
have yeah
a lot of people requesting stuff and all
that what not
iron ghost 1982 says what race class
specs do you guys play in wow
well i haven't played i played
shadowlands a little bit when it came
out and i kind of just rolled my eyes
like hey
you know there's only so much i can do
with the story and uh but
i worked really hard to get a void elf
and now i have a void elf rogue because
um it's been too long since i played but
the
the void elf has the teleport ability
you guys i don't know the void elf new
race
yeah it's it's from um i think legion
you got a complete maybe it's not i
think it's legion maybe i'm wrong
you have to complete a whole bunch of
quests it's been a while since i played
it it's like a year ago
and then once you finally complete
everything you unlock this special race
with evan ability
where they throw a rift and then you can
blink like teleport to the rift
so i love doing pvp with my rogue and
then i'll like slice and dice somebody
up and then once i kill one of their
dudes and they're about to kill me i
just throw the rift and then go the
other direction tim is pure rogue by the
way we played
last year human robe no
wow you were here yeah yeah yeah well i
unlocked void elf rogue in the middle of
mine's uh night elf druid
that's my go-to which is sort of chris
it's just the best you can walk around
to be free but a rogue
a druid can turn into a cat and play
like a rogue not international
stealth is not as good no it's not and
uh druid can heal though
that's true druids are pretty fun
because they can do everything we got a
big old super chat here
uh sh says these people saying games
desensitize you to violence against
others are just wrong
the amount of problems we soldiers face
after killing sticks with us for a long
time and causes many problems for
from drinking to suicide nothing helps
us deal with taking another life
yeah man life is not uh this stuff is
yeah it's bad the double x-54 says hey
mac
i'm i'm in the northern va area how do i
volunteer for your organization
when you guys are up here uh well we're
we're getting started there we have a
volunteer forum on our site where you
can tell us
what you're capable of doing what you
have to offer look at america.org
volunteer so sign up please very cool
all right let's see we'll just grab a
couple more super chats
gavin roth says i think y'all were
talking about uss coal bombing back in
2000 in yemen
correct suicide bombers disguised
themselves as a small merchant ship and
detonated right next to the coal
that bombing completely changed security
posture for the navy
wow crazy alex flores says why no ben
shapiro you
ben shapiro you've been on his sunday
special so
in order to do that um this is before we
had good internet i
had to record we had a with a low
quality
like audio call and then i recorded with
a camera hard to the camera
took the memory card out and had it
driven up three hours away
and then uploaded from a high speed
source
to a shared server they could download
the footage and then they synchronized
it with the call
and their footage on their end it was
not easy and all these lefties were like
you did a skype with ben shapiro and i'm
like first of all that was his show not
our show we don't do
uh phone calls or skype calls for a
variety of reasons
but we welcome people to come here and i
tell people listen did you realize that
nobody has any screens i've got one
screen and then no one else has like
everyone's got their own phones their
own laptops we just
we're not set up for it and i'll tell
you this a lot of other big podcasts
won't do it either
there are some well i'm not going to
call out but they did it a few times and
then like i've talked to a lot of these
people and they're like wow that was a
mistake
it like doesn't work the engagement goes
way down people aren't happy with it
they complain about it
there are people who just want to see
you know internet blood sports we don't
do that we like having conversations in
person
all right let's see someone mentioned
that donald.win
is gone but it's now i believe was it
patriots patriots dot win
yeah patriots.when it's the same thing
they just changed the name i guess
because
donald trump's not president anymore
yeah so that makes sense
all right well we'll do uh just one more
crazy eye says
m4s are full auto now burst stamped out
and has auto now was in national guard
got out in 2019.
interesting well everybody thank you all
so much for hanging out make sure you
smash the like button subscribe the
notification
bell go to timcast.com become a member
because we are gonna have a bonus
segment but uh
matt do you wanna mention your
organization again and anything people
need to know about how to helping get
involved sure i mean we're looking for
volunteers we're also looking for donors
everything helps that you can do it
doesn't matter what part of the country
you're in
i will find a way to put you to work as
a grassroots
grassroots lobbyist for helping us
register new voters so it's
lookaheadamerica.org
right on and luke i hear you have
t-shirts i think it's fair to say i have
the best political shirts because i own
the domain
the best political shirts dot com see
you see what i did there you know
you can also find me on luke we are
change
on twitter and uh instagram so yeah
check me out there thanks oh
there's the store when you go to the
best political shirts it jumps you to
the we are change
store yeah check out the bikinis check
out the socks defund the media
i tweeted that did you steal that from
me i i steal everything i don't know
what you're talking about
everything i see i just gobble it up i'm
like that's a good shirt idea he
liberated it yes
i've been on this venture youtube
literally turned me into a t-shirt
vendor i mean
getting out the messaging i probably got
more views on my shirts than my videos
because of how many different shirts i
had to create to offset
me losing my youtube revenue because i
used to survive off making you know
money off the youtube ads
and now people buy this trump face
sweater yes
yeah i do i wear it all the time it's
very obnoxious and it's a very uh
you know it's it's peculiar but uh it's
you know i want to make uh uh a line of
clothing with little pictures of animals
on it yeah
we're gonna i think we already do that i
know and i'm gonna do it too and i'm
gonna i'm not gonna do the political
see you see the i am a gorilla shirt
that we have if you want to get your
exclusive i am a gorilla t-shirt go to
timcast.com
click shop boom it's right there and
good news youtube has finally integrated
it into
the system so we are waiting for it to
be reviewed
it's funny it's literally just a gorilla
as i'm a gorilla but youtube's like we
got to make sure it's safe
it's a big brain gorilla by the way he's
a he's got a big
frontal lobe smart feller and so that's
why we're going to do the uh the tin
foil hat one soon
maybe maybe next week we got it ready to
go and everything and that's going to be
special edition which will only sell for
probably one week from like a thursday
to thursday thing so
because you people are mentioning their
paychecks or whatever on friday but uh
yeah go to timcast.com become a member
we have a bonus segment coming up but uh
ian you want to mention yeah two things
one i don't think druids are better than
rogues i think rogues are probably the
best
might even be the best class in the game
but i like the versatility personally i
like the versatility of the druid
uh number two is i'm ian crossland you
can follow me online at twitter mine's
youtube
facebook instagram and uh later on
tonight i'm gonna be gaming with adam
kriegler on twitch.tv slash ian
crossland
come follow me there and check it out
we're gonna be playing red dead
redemption two
very excited to roll the posse and
thanks for having me tim
that'll be fun yeah so i'm kind of like
refereeing this wild ride over here i'm
sorry guys it's crazy but you know you
love it
i'm sour patch lids on twitter l-y-d-s
and i'm real sour patch lids on
mines and gab and instagram
is that right something like that you
can find me on all those places
you can follow me on twitter instagram
minds at tim cast check out my other
youtube channels
youtube.comtymcastyoutube.comcastnews
we'll be back tomorrow at 8 p.m
live but don't forget we're actually
gonna have some bonus segments i believe
we might even have more than one we'll
see how things play out but that's at
timcast.com check it out
and become a member and if you do run
into any issues go to
uh email members timcast.com my
apologies we're getting everything
sorted
but other than that we will see you in
the bonus segment or tomorrow at 8pm
live
thanks for hanging out bye guys
you